Wir blicken heute in der Ligatour unter anderem auf Marseille, Napoli, Almeria und – wir wollen natürlich auch noch mal kurz sprechen – über die Fanproteste in der Liga und ob sowas in den anderen Ligen wohl denkbar werde. Jetzt gleich mit Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy, Marius Soyke und Uli Hebel gibt's später auch noch zu hören.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich grüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und ich grüße meine Runde. Wir beginnen mit einem Thema aus der Bundesliga. Ihr habt es ja alle mitbekommen, die Fanproteste in der Bundesliga, unter anderem die Fanproteste haben dazu geführt und die Diskussion danach, dass es jetzt keinen Investoreneinstieg gibt. Sehr fantastisches Timing von der DFL. Wir haben gerade zwei Stunden bevor diese Meldung kam, die Sendung veröffentlicht zum Deal aus Investorensicht. Ich glaube allerdings, dass man die immer noch sehr gut hören kann. Also dieses Tribüngespräch hat auch schon viel Resonanz bekommen. Also hört es euch gerne mal an. Man versteht dann nämlich, dass die Probleme jetzt nicht weggehen werden, die es aktuell in der Liga gibt. Und ich glaube, es ist auch gar nicht so schlecht zu wissen, wie CWC so funktioniert. Denn die hängen ja bei zwei von drei von euch drin. Und bei der Serie A, da klopfen sie ja immer noch an. Deswegen würde ich gerne mal einsteigen. Nils, nimmt man denn in La Liga wahr, was gerade da Antennisbällen aufs Feld geflogen ist in der Bundesliga und wäre sowas in Spanien auch denkbar?
Guten Morgen. Also ein paar Videos und Fotos von ferngesteuerten Autos gab es schon auch bei Marker und Co. zu sehen. Aber einfach weil es ja kurios ist.
Das war der Turning Point, oder? Als es nicht mehr Tennisbälle waren, sondern irgendwelche Autos.
Ich glaube, das war schon besonders kreativ. Aber ich glaube, in Spanien gibt es ja seit 2021 ist CWC als Investor eingestiegen. Und ich glaube, die hatten damals versprochen, 3 Milliarden Euro, kriegen dafür 10 Prozent für die nächsten 50 Jahre. So genau, sicher bin ich mit den Zahlen jetzt nicht mehr. Aber damals war der Protest überschaubar. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist nur noch Real Madrid und Athletic Club, also aus Bilbao, die klagen dagegen. Barca war anfangs auch dabei, aber ist mittlerweile eingeknickt. Und weil es eben, ich würde sagen, die finanzielle Situation vieler Vereine ein bisschen schlimmer vielleicht ist als in der Bundesliga, war der Protest auch auf Fan-Seite eher überschaubar. Mittlerweile haben sich da auch viele Infrastrukturen verbessert. Also viele Clubs wie Mallorca, wie Areal, haben ihre Stadien verbessert. Deswegen war der Protest da sehr überschaubar, außer wie gesagt bei Real Madrid und dem Athletik-Club. Ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, dass sich die generelle Situation deutlich verbessert hat. Das war jetzt erst mal schnelles Geld. Und ich glaube, die Folgen wird man jetzt erst mal noch spüren, wenn, wie gesagt, die Vereine erst mal die nächsten Jahre 10 Prozent weniger einnehmen. Aber Protest waren überschaubar bisher in Spanien.
Genau. Also es waren zwei Milliarden für 8, 2 Prozent. Aber ganz wichtig sind eben die 50 Jahre. Und ich habe in Vorbereitung auf das Tribügenspräch, was ich gestern aufgezeichnet habe, noch mal einen Real Madrid Podcast von 2021 nachgehört, wo sie noch mal – why this is the most terrible deal for La Liga – wo sie noch mal genau erklärt haben, warum Real auch dagegen geklagt hat. Und man muss sagen, sie haben komplett recht, über 50 Jahre eine Erlösbeteiligung abzustoßen. Das ist ungefähr auf einem Level mit Chicago, die mal ihr komplettes Parkgebührensystem für 60 Jahre verkauft haben und viel zu wenig Kohle dafür gekriegt haben. Viel zu wenig! Es ist absurd wenig. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. David, die Liga hängt ja auch mit CWC zusammen. Da gibt es ja sogar Ermittlungen von der Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt, weil da vielleicht persönliche Bereicherung stattgefunden haben könnte beim Abschluss dieses Deals. Da müssen wir jetzt glaube ich nicht in die Details gehen, sind ja auch noch laufende Verfahren. Aber hat man das registriert, dass es die Liga hier in Deutschland geschafft hat, sich gegen CWC zu wehren, wenn man das zumindest aus Sicht der Kritiker sieht?
Also die Medien von heute Morgen habe ich ja so nicht gescannt, alle inwieweit da jetzt, weil du gesagt hast, geschafft hast zu wehren. Das war ja bis gestern noch nicht ganz raus. Aber den Protest, ähnlich wie in Spanien, hat man schon auch gemerkt, weil er kreativ war. Ja, ich glaube aber, dass insgesamt das Thema halt in Frankreich einfach durch ist. Also da war ja diese Sache mit dem…
Für immer durch.
Für immer durch. Also und wenn wir es gerade nochmal so schön im Ohr haben, jetzt was es in Spanien gab, in Frankreich gab es 1, 5 Milliarden für 13 Prozent.
Für immer.
Für immer. Für immer. Und es wurde halt damals argumentiert mit Corona und den geschlossenen Stadien und sehr, sehr, sehr hohen Schulden, wo einige Klubs wirklich mit dem Rücken vor der Wand standen und glaube ich gar keine andere Möglichkeit hatten. Die brauchten dieses Geld, das wären die Pleite gewesen oder haben das zumindest befürchtet. Und deswegen sind sie diesen Deal eingegangen. Und ja, es gibt immer wieder nochmal, wird nochmal erwähnt, dass da nochmal versucht wird zu klagen oder ähnliches. Aber erstmal steht dieses Ding. Also das ist…
Also dieser Deal in der Liga, das ist wirklich das Krasseste überhaupt. Und man muss auch sagen, das habe ich gestern ins Tribügenspräch gar nicht mal reingepackt, aber im direkten Vergleich – wir haben ja jetzt gerade die Zahlen nochmal gehört – wäre der deutsche Deal sogar gut gewesen. Also weil eben nur 20 Jahre, weil eben eine Milliarde, das hätte so von den Zahlen her, war das eigentlich ganz okay. Es wäre auch am schnellsten vorbei gewesen. Also wenn man davon ausgeht, ein Investor geht nochmal raus, kann man seine Bedenken dazu haben. Aber ja, ganz interessant. Und in der Serie A, Marius, da wollten einige Vereine, andere wollten wir nicht. Die Lorenzoni haben ihr, glaube ich, schon mehrmals zitiert, der dann immer irgendwelche anderen Vorschläge gemacht hat. Aber hat man die Fanproteste da wahrgenommen?
Ich würde das auch vergleichen mit dem, was Nils und David gesagt haben. Also das ist sicherlich Fotos, Videos in den Medien schon mal gegeben hat. Aber ansonsten kann ich mir auch in der Serie A so Proteste in der Form, wie wir sie in der Bundesliga oder in der 2. Liga gesehen haben, eigentlich nicht vorstellen, weil so diese gesamte Investorenkultur in Italien eine ganz andere ist als in Deutschland. Klar gibt es sehr kritische Fans, das bezieht sich dann aber meistens auf die Klubschefs selbst oder auf, wenn es mal wieder irgendwelche Skandale in der Liga gibt. Aber solche politischen Entscheidungen spielen dann, glaube ich, in dem Selbstverständnis der Ultras nicht so eine große Rolle da, wie es im deutschen Fußball der Fall ist.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Es sind einfach unterschiedliche Fan-Kulturen, aber deswegen fand ich diesen Blick auch so interessant.
Dann lassen wir uns gerade nochmal extra kurz in das Equipment rein schauen von heute Morgen. Also es ist eine kleine Meldung. Auf Seite 10 oder so. Hintertuchel.
Ja gut, das kann man ja sogar halbwegs verstehen. Da hat er sogar einen Bezug zur Liga. Na gut, vielleicht war es dann hier dann doch etwas größer. Aber dann lass doch mal reingehen in die Ligen. Und da haben wir ein Thema, was am aktuellsten ist, nämlich der Blick auf Napoli, Marius. Denn die haben erst gestern Abend in der Champions League gespielt gegen Barca. Gibt es etwas, was wir zu diesem Spiel wissen müssen? Und was sagt das Spiel über den aktuellen Zustand von Neapel aus?
Das Spiel selbst habe ich tatsächlich nicht gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, Nils, hast du dir das angeguckt? Nur was ich dazu gelesen habe, dass Barca eigentlich besser war. Und Barca ist ja auch, glaube ich, jetzt nicht so fantastisch in Form. Und dass der Punkt, oder das Unentschiedene aus Napoli Sicht, im Endeffekt eher glücklich war, was aber auch irgendwie zur Gesamtsituation passt. Denn Napoli hat nur zwei Tage vorher mal wieder den Trainer gewechselt. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Geschichte der Serie A gab, einen Meister gab, der sich in der Folgesaison derart selbst demontiert hat, wie Napoli oder wie de Laurentius, der Präsident, das geschafft hat. Carl Zona ist der neue Mann an der Linie, der hat von Walter Marzalli übernommen, der ja im November von Rüdiger Sier übernommen hatte. Ich erinnere mich, dass wir über Rüdiger Sier hier auch, oder dass ich über Rüdiger Sier hier auch schon mal im Herbst gesprochen habe. Und ja, Napoli ist aktuell weit davon entfernt, überhaupt wieder in die Champions League zu kommen. Deswegen glaube ich, erst mal mit dem Punkt gegen einen FC Barcelona, auch wenn der gut in Form ist, lebt man und vor allem freut man sich, dass Viktor Osimen wieder da ist nach Afrika Cup Finale und so weiter und so fort. Hat er jetzt glaube ich zum ersten Mal wieder gespielt, direkt getroffen. Das ergibt sicherlich irgendwo Optimismus. Der Trainer der neue Calzona, das ist ein bisschen eine romantische Geschichte, der war Co-Trainer unter Maurizio Sarri schon in Empoli und auch in Napoli insgesamt unter Sarri sechs Jahre. Er hat auch unter Spalletti den Techniktrainer gegeben. Also der kennt die Mannschaft, der kennt den Verein sehr gut und soll, glaube ich, die Fans so ein bisschen milde stimmen, nachdem man vorher neun Monate lang alles an die Wand gefahren hat, was vorher so ungefähr aufgebaut worden ist. Ob er das jetzt aus spielerischer Sicht schaffen kann, da wieder was zu etablieren, was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise mit dem Vergleich ist, was wir letzte Saison gesehen haben, was uns begeistert hat, das kann ich ehrlich gesagt so genau nicht sagen. Der ist Slowakischer Nationaltrainer seit 2022, hat da einen guten Punkteschnitt, hat die EM erreicht. Slowakische Nationale Mannschaft habe ich mir aber nicht so oft angeguckt in der Vergangenheit. Er kommt von Sarri, er kommt von Spalletti, also der sollte eigentlich schon irgendwie für einen offensiven Fußball stehen und ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen Besänftigung und vielleicht noch das Hoffen, dass man Conference League oder Europa League erreicht. Also ich blicke da auf jeden Fall gespannt. Der Vorgänger, Marzari, wir haben ihn bei Serie A Moro so ein bisschen salopp als den Neuruhrer des italienischen Fußballs bezeichnet, was ihm wahrscheinlich nicht so ganz gerecht wird. Er ist halt ein Trainer, der komplett aus der Zeit gefallen ist, also den du eigentlich generell nicht mehr bei den italienischen Erstligisten so wirklich auf die Bank setzen kannst und vor allem nicht bei einem, der für Spielkultur steht und der für, also der Ambitionen hat, irgendwas zu erreichen in der Liga, außer vielleicht den Klassenerhalt. Und entsprechend sah das dann auch auf dem Platz aus, also einen taktischen Plan hast du nicht erkennen können. Er hat relativ häufig auch in Spielen das System gewechselt. Er wusste nicht, wie er Quichar-Quaratzquilla richtig einsetzen soll. Natürlich hat dem Ozymen dann auch sowohl durch Afrika Cup als auch durch Verletzung gefehlt. Das ist dann immer sehr schwierig. Aber ja, es war ein erwartbarer Schuss in den Ofen einfach und 1, 24 Punkte im Schnitt aus – was habe ich mir aufgeschrieben? 17 Spielen. Das gab es zuletzt schlechter im Jahr 2009 unter Roberto Donadoni. Also das ist auch ungefähr vergleichbar mit der Zeitspanne. Thomas Tuchel hat ja bei den Bayern den schlechtesten Punkt des Schnitts seit Jürgen Klinsmann. Also ganz, ganz knapp von Kahl, ganz, ganz knapp besser, aber ja, ist so. Also so lange her ist das, dass es bei Napoli mal schlechter lief und entsprechend ist das jetzt so irgendwie der letzte Strohhalm und ich glaube, die Fans finden es so vom Romantik-Faktor her ganz gut.
Der Romantik-Faktor. Ich muss noch ganz kurz sagen, ich habe vorhin, glaube ich, de Lorenzoni gesagt. Ich meinte natürlich de Laurentes. Keine Ahnung, was da los war. Es ist in meinem Kopf auch noch sehr früh. Als ich es gesagt habe, dachte ich mir noch so, das klingt irgendwie total falsch. Wer war das nochmal? Der von Napoli halt. Also de Laurentes habe ich gemeint.
Genau. Und de Lorenzo ist der Kapitän. Also vielleicht war das so ein bisschen die.
Ja, wahrscheinlich kam es da. Das würde zumindest erklären, weil ansonsten ergibt es ja gar keinen Sinn. Aber gut, machen wir nicht größer.
Ich dachte gerade, du kannst doch Max nicht solche Türen öffnen, hier mit Trainer-Vergleichen und Bundesliga-Vergleichen. Dem leuchten auch schon die Augen. Ich habe gleich noch den Joe Biden auf der Trainerbank.
Oh, sehr schön. Das ist dann natürlich der deutsche Otto Rehagel. Ja, gut. Aber da kommen wir noch. Nils, du hast vorhin so ein bisschen genickt, als es um das Champions-League-Spiel ging. Ich konnte es leider auch nicht sehen. Ich sehe nur, Napoli hatte 6 Schüsse und Barca 12. Also es war jetzt kein Spektakel. Konntest du es näher verfolgen?
Ja, es lief so nebenbei. Und klar hatte Barca hier und da mehr Anteile und ein, zwei bessere Abschlüsse. Aber es war jetzt auch nicht eine drückende Überlegenheit. Ich würde fast sagen, dass Napoli ein bisschen gesagt hat, ihr könnt den Ball haben und wir warten auf unsere Chance. Ich glaube, der X-G-Wert war am Ende bei Napoli auch höher als bei Barca. Also, obwohl Barca deutlich mehr Abschlüsse hatte. Deswegen so gefährlich wurde Barca auch nicht. Deswegen glaube ich, defensiv kann das schon Hoffnung machen, auch wenn Lewandowski ein bisschen zu viel Platz hatte bei Barca. Aber den 90 Minuten auszuschalten, auch wenn jetzt keine überragende Saisonspiel ist, ist ja auch nicht ganz so einfach. Von dem her kann man glaube ich schon auch ein bisschen zufrieden sein für das erste Spiel. Natürlich war es offensiv noch zu wenig und am Ende war es auch ein Patzer, glaube ich von Inigo Martinez hat sich einmal ein bisschen abkochen lassen von Orsiment bei dem Tor. Aber es war jetzt kein überragendes Barca und die sind auch ein bisschen in der Form Krise und von dem her ja traurig ist man trotzdem glaube ich eher in Barcelona, dass man da zwei Punkte, die nicht noch mitgenommen hat, auch wenn es jetzt nicht so übertrieben verdient gewesen wäre meiner Meinung nach.
Und könnt ihr euch in euren Ligen, Nils, David, könnt ihr euch an einen Fall erinnern, wo eben der Meister so viele Probleme hatte in der Folgesaison und es gab ja gar nicht die krassen Abgänge halt außer auf der Trainerposition natürlich, aber jetzt sind es neun Punkte hinter dem internationalen Geschäft. Gut, Conference League könnte ihm vielleicht auch weniger Punkte reichen, aber Napoli ist ja wirklich mitten im Mittelfeld der Tabelle. David, hast du da einen vergleichbaren Fall aus der Liga gerade im Kopf?
Dass der Meister sich demontiert hat selbst. Na ja gut, zumindest im letzten Jahrzehnt hatten wir ja abgesehen von den PSG-Meisterschaften dann immer wieder kleinere Mannschaften, die selbst demontiert wurden durch das Klassische, was halt passiert, dass die die Mannschaft weggekauft wird oder dass sie halt dann mit Champions League nicht zurecht kommen und all dem. Aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz so zu vergleichen, würde ich sagen. Ansonsten schafft PSG es durchaus, sich gelegentlich zu demontieren, aber es halt trotzdem nach Hause zu schaukeln. Insofern nein, ich glaube, die Situation ist nicht ganz dieselbe.
Und in der Liga hatten wir das damals auch nicht so wirklich, oder?
Ja, natürlich ist oft Real und Barca und Real schafft es nie, irgendwie den Titel zu verteidigen. Das letzte Mal war 2007, glaube ich, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sich Real danach komplett demontiert. Ich überlege gerade so Anfang der 2000er. Anfang der 2000er gab es ja diese Valencia-Meisterschaften, die zwei. Aber ich glaube, da war es dann eher, dass dann einfach irgendwann der Kader auch oder so ein bisschen Ausverkauf stattgefunden hat. Vielleicht gehen die besten Spieler. Das war jetzt bei Napoli nicht der Fall. Ossimian, Quartz, Gelia sind ja alle noch da. Von dem her tue ich mich da jetzt schwer, auch so einen Vergleich zu ziehen. Ich glaube, das ist schon vielleicht einmalig. Deportivo vielleicht noch. Superdepot ist einen tiefen Fall, aber das hat auch noch mal, hat auch Wahnsinnsgründe teilweise. Also, dass sie dem Wahnsinn verfallen sind vielleicht.
Und das passierte ja auch nicht im Jahr direkt nach der Meisterschaften. Also ich meine, Champions League-Halbfinale und so kam ja auch erst danach noch.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Es ist unvergleichlich, was Napoli hier schafft. Auch wenn das vielleicht etwas ist, was man nicht haben will. Aber immerhin ist man den italienischen Neurohre losgeworden und hat jetzt was fürs Herz. Und dann muss man halt irgendwie diese Saison zu Ende bringen. Und wir bleiben ja sowieso dran. Dann lasst mal in die Ligue 1 springen. Da haben wir nämlich auch durchaus ein bisschen Turbulenzen. Also wenn wir gerade bei Napoli sagen, die haben schon wieder den Trainer entlassen. Mit Marseille können sie nur nicht komplett mithalten, David.
Och ja, das klang schon gerade sehr, sehr vergleichbar, muss ich sagen. Aber ich rekapituliere nochmal kurz für uns alle. Also im Juli war ja Marseilinho gekommen und der war im September direkt wieder gegangen, weil da die Fan-Proteste so aggressiv nach dem Champions-League-Quali aus waren. Ich glaube, da hatte Alexi eine Ligatur zu gemacht, bin mir nicht mehr. Aber ich meine, ich habe da was im Ohr. Die Fans hatten damals die gesamte Führungsriege zum Rücktritt aufgefordert und Marseille stand zum Saisonbeginn gar nicht so schlecht da, aber Marseilinho hat dann gesagt, ne, ne, also das ist unter den Umständen, das ist, das kann er nicht, das ist ihm zu heikel und oder man könnte auch sagen, er ist geopfert worden, je nachdem. Dann kam ein Interimstrainer, dann kam Ende September Gattuso. Der hat sich jetzt seit Wochen beschwert, dass der Kader zu wenig Talent hat und die Spieler zu wenig Charakter haben und dann musste er jetzt, weil Afrika Cup war, hatte er teilweise nur zehn Spieler auf dem Platz und musste dann mit Jugendspielern das auffüllen und war dann erst recht erschüttert, wie wenig die Jugendspieler an Talent noch dann mitbringen. Umgekehrt haben ihn die Spieler immer wieder aufgeholt, er soll doch bitte zu ihrem 3-5-2 umstellen, das passt besser zur Mannschaft und Gattuso hat gesagt, nö, ich mach mein 4-3-3 und am Ende wirkte er sehr, sehr ratlos. Also die Mannschaft immer wieder Tore auch in der letzten Minute gefangen und seine Reaktion, wenn er angesprochen wurde darauf war, dann ja, ich bin nicht der Mentaltrainer hier. Also das, ähm, merkt euch das mal, da kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drauf auf den Mentaltrainer. Ja, also sehr viel Konflikt, dann die ambeziehende Fanszene. Man könnte auch sagen, nichts Neues bei Marseille, sehr viel Chaos und dann hattest du am Sonntag eben die Niederlage gegen Brest. Da haben schon andere verloren gegen Brest, auch das hat Alexi in der vorletzten Folge schön ausgeführt, dass die gerade Überraschungsteam sind. Aber das war schon sehr trostlos. Also da kam ein Schuss von Marseille, irgendwann 80er, ich glaube 87er, irgendwas Minute durch Aubameyang. Das heißt, Brest hatte die besseren Chancen und wohlgemerkt in einem Spiel, in dem beide Teams ihre Ersatz-Türhüter im Tor hatten. Ja, also Bilanz, kein ernster Sieg für Marseille 2024 bislang. Im Pokal ausgeschieden gegen den Fünftligisten, US-Tionville. Übrigens, Rabbit Hole bei der Recherche. Für den US-Tionville hat mal Fritz Walter gespielt, als der Verein noch Tus Lidenhofen hieß, weil die Moser-Region ja im 1. und 2. Weltkrieg immer wieder zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich in ein Hotel gewechselt ist.
Hey, David, wirklich, hier jetzt Fritz Walter unterzubringen.
Also Marseille 30 Punkte, Platz 9, 6 Punkte von den Europa-League-Rängen entfernt. Das sieht nicht gut aus und deswegen haben sie jetzt Gattuso entlassen und es ist jetzt, seit vorgestern, Jean-Louis Gasset. Der war schon mal Feuerwehrmann. Der hat bei Saint-Étienne 2017 und auch bei Montpellier beide Mal als recht erfolgreich sogar als Feuerwehrmann die Mannschaften gerettet. Bei Saint-Étienne auch wieder kleiner Seitenschleifer, hat das mit dem Transfermarkt ganz gut geklappt. Da kam er in der Winterpause, da hat er Namen verpflichtet wie M. Villard, Debussy, Neven Subotage. Das hilft natürlich ein bisschen, wenn man mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht, dass die Chance hat er diesmal nicht. Dafür kam er jetzt zu spät. 70 Jahre alt, falls da was bei euch klingelt. Ja, genau, das war derjenige, der von der Elfenbeinküste zum Start des Turniers entlassen wurde.
Genau, deswegen kam er nämlich so spät, weil er erst noch die Vorrunde verkacken musste mit der Elfenbeinküste, nachdem nur zu viel entlassen wurde.
Genau, da hat sich übrigens gestern ein gewisser Sébastien Haller im Fernsehen zu Wort gemeldet und gesagt, also Gasset, der sei als Trainer menschlich, das sei wie ein gutmütiger und respektarer Großvater, der hat sich in höchsten Tönen geäußert. Da gehe es sehr viel um menschliche Nähe und um Dialog. Gasset interessanterweise hat auch, jetzt stellt das so dar, dass er seinen Rückblick selbst angereicht hat, also dass er selbst vorgeschlagen hat, er sollte gehen, weil er sei von negativen Schwingungen umgeben gewesen. Direkt nach seiner Ankunft sei der Generalsekretär verstorben und dann die Krebserkrankung Wunderlehr und die Auftrag in der Lage, die Verletzungen und da hat er gesagt, also mein Weggang hat die Situation gerettet, da gab es einen Schuldigen und die Ahnen konnten weitermachen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob er sich das da, ich kann es nicht sagen, ob er sich das da schön redet, aber wenn es tatsächlich stimmt, dann war es ein Boss-Move, weil wie gesagt, Magüste hat das Turnier gewonnen.
Hört die Sendung dazu, wenn ihr es noch nicht gehört habt, liebe Hörer und Hörerinnen und Hörer, da haben wir das nochmal aufgearbeitet. Das heißt, Marseille, da heißt ab jetzt, durch diese Hohle Gasset wird er kommen. Aber glaubst du, dass er das hinbekommen kann? Ich meine, wir haben ja über Marseille jetzt schon öfter gesprochen. Es ist ja vor allem unspektakulär, was da passiert und das wiederum bricht sich mit dem Umfeld.
Ja, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass er zumindest die Saison beruhigt zum Ende manövrieren kann. Auch das ist von vornherein klar. Er soll nicht länger bleiben. Er soll Feuerwehrmann sein. Er soll im Sommer wieder gehen. Es wird gemunkelt, dass sie spekulieren, dass sie Christophe Galtier absommer haben wollen. Das war derjenige, den wir von PSG und von Nizza kennen, der mit Rassismusvorwürfen sogar vor Gericht stand. Mittlerweile ist er vor Gericht, aber freigesprochen worden. Es wirkt schon so, als könnte er jemand sein, der zumindest diese ganze Situation gerade sehr beruhigt. Dass er ein bisschen mehr auf die Spieler hören will. Angesprochen, ob er einen Mentaltrainer einstellen möchte. Er hat gestern in der PK gesagt, dass er ein Mentaltrainer ist. Er hat dann Dinge erzählt, wie die Spieler waren erstaunt, dass er zu jedem von ihnen eine Anekdote zu erzählen hätte und dass er sie mit Vornamen angesprochen hätte und dass er ihnen Vertrauen geben möchte, aber das hat der Gattuso gemacht.
Wobei du vorhin schon so wissend genickt hast, als das hieß ja mit Gattuso lief es nicht so. Konnte man das etwa ahnen?
Ja, also ich sage mal Gattuso, er tut mir immer so ein bisschen Leid in den Entscheidungen, die er trifft bei seiner Vereinsauswahl. Also ich meine, das fing bei ihm als Trainer an, beim FC Sion. Wer den Verein kennt, der hat, glaube ich, 70 Trainer in den letzten zehn Jahren verschlissen. Dann kam er zu US-Palermo, da war es ähnlich. In Kreta ist er zurückgetreten, weil der Präsident irgendwie auch verrückt war oder so. Dann hat er Milan übernommen in der Post-Bellos-Coni-Ära, da lief es auch drunter und drüber, bevor Maldini und so dann zurückgekommen sind. Valencia zuletzt. Da kann Nils auch mehr zu sagen, aber es läuft auch nicht so rund. Und dann Marseille in einer Saison, wo es losgeht, weil der Trainer zurücktritt wegen Fan-Protesten. Also das ist schon entweder sehr schlechte Beratung oder über großes Ego.
Boah, dann kann man sich aber auf ihn bei Schalke richtig freuen.
Ja, also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, das werden jetzt wahrscheinlich relativ einfache Rezepte werden. Er wird genau das machen, was die Spiele gefordert haben, eben zum 352 zurückkehren. Die haben heute Abend ein sehr wichtiges, schwere Spiel gegen Schakta, den in Europa liegt. Da können wir gleich mal sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Er hat den Spielern auch gesagt, naja, also ich bin in vier Monaten weg. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, ihr müsst das ausbaden, nicht ich. Und ja, mal sehen. Übrigens, apropos Trainersuche und so weiter. Es gab in der Zeit schrift So Food mit dem Präsidenten von Marseille in Hongouria ein sehr, sehr spannendes Interview, wo er unter anderem erzählt hat, dass er im Sommer auf Alonso zugegangen sei. Und Alonso gefragt hätte, ob der gerne Marseille trainieren möchte. Und Alonso hätte ihn auf sehr, sehr freundliche Art und Weise direkt nach fünf Minuten nein gesagt. Aber das sei so freundlich und so wunderbar gewesen, dass sie anschließend noch drei Stunden über Fußball geredet hätte.
Das kann ja im FC Bayern Hoffnung machen, dass man wenigstens noch ein gutes Gespräch mit dir führen kann, wenn man die Absage gekriegt hat. Ach schön. Ja, dann schauen wir doch mal, was gegen Schachter geht. Man hat auswärts bzw. auswärts bedeutet er in diesem Fall Hamburg 2 zu 2 gespielt gegen Donetsk. Jetzt heute Abend dann eben das Rückspiel in der Europa League. Vielleicht hilft er dann schon das Handauflegen von Gazet und mit Marseille geht es positiver weiter. Danke dir, David. Ich würde sagen, wir springen in den Abstiegskampf. Da habt ihr nämlich alle so ein bisschen was mitgebracht bzw. bei David muss ich es einschränken. Aber in La Liga, da läuft es nicht so. Und zwar für Almeria, die man hier auch noch kennt. Da haben wir mal einen Kurzpass zugenommen, der inzwischen Tribügensprech geworden ist. Werde ich verlinken. Nils, was ist los?
Was ist los? Viel ist los. Wenn wir uns so alle Ligen in Europa, die Top-Ligen anschauen, ich glaube, da gibt es keinen so schlechten Tabellenletzten, weil Almeria ist auch nach 25 Spieltagen immer noch sieglos. Das ist jetzt sogar ein La-Liga-Rekord mit den letzten drei Spieltagen der Vorsitzenden. Also 28, das ist so schlecht, war noch nie ein Erstligist, dass er so lange ohne Sieg war der Letzte im Mai. Und trotz dem nur 8 Punkten, 8 unentschieden, dass sie überhaupt noch so ein bisschen Restfunk und Hoffnung haben, liegt daran, dass Granada und Kadiz quasi fast genauso schwach sind. Die haben immerhin zweimal gewonnen. Aber das ist schon ein sehr schwaches Abstiegs-Trio da unten. Ich glaube, vor einem Jahr am 25. Spieltag hatten die drei da unten allein 15 Punkte mehr. Aber es soll um Almeria gehen und ich denke mal, viele Zuhörer und Zuhörerinnen wissen, dass dort auch ein Scheich seinen Unwesen treibt, wobei man jetzt nicht alles nur auf ihn schieben kann. Aber man merkt schon, Almeria ist so ein Verein, wo in jeder Saison irgendwie 15 oder 20 neue Spieler gehen. Also eine enorme Fluktuation. Auch dieses Jahr hast du eigentlich ein paar gute Einzelspieler dabei, Luis Suárez – nein, nicht den ihr kennt, sondern der andere, der hat schon oft in der Liga geknipst, mit Sergio Arribas, ein Talent von Real Madrid. Viele, die eigentlich schon kicken können, aber da geht sehr wenig zusammen. Almeria ist so auch die deutlich schwächste Defensive der Liga mit 52 Gegentoren. Die kassieren auch, lassen auch die meisten Abschlüsse zu auf ihr eigenes Tor. Also da ist wenig Harmonie in der Mannschaft. Die bringen die PS nicht so richtig auf die Straße. Und vielleicht auch irgendwo eine Trainersache. Garry Tano ist schon der zweite Trainer in dieser Saison, aber jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile dabei und bringt irgendwie keinen Erfolg oder zumindest hat er noch nicht diesen ersten erhofften Saisonsieg gebracht. Letztes Jahr war es noch Ruby, ihr Aufstiegstrainer. Der hatte den Klassenerhalt geschafft, aber der ist dann im Sommer freiwillig zurückgetreten, hat bis heute keinen neuen Job. Also der wird schon sich auch gedacht haben, ich bringe es irgendwie zu Ende bis Saisonende, aber noch eine Saison tue ich mir das nicht an. Also es ist, glaube ich, vielleicht kein einfacher Verein zu arbeiten.
Wir haben damals über Almeria gesprochen in einer Extra-Sendung. Da ging es um Barry Bolton, Almeria und Malaga. Und ich sehe hier in der Beschreibung Lizenzentzug, Rettung in letzter Sekunde, Investorenspielzeug und Hashtag Okazaki Day. Das war, glaube ich, Malaga. Was war denn noch mal Almeria von den Punkten?
Okazaki, das war es jetzt nicht, aber wahrscheinlich dann generell die Scheichssache, dass seit 2019 ist Turkey als Scheich dabei und der ist ja auch in Saudi-Arabien mit in diesem Regierungsministerium, der, glaube ich, auch diese Saudi-Vision 2034 mitleitet. Auf jeden Fall der ist dort Eigentümerpräsident und hat eben auch schon viele Trainer natürlich verschlissen, auch mal gerne nach Namen eingekauft. Guti war so ein berühmter Name, also die Reallegende, die mal kurz da war. Der tut an sich vor Ort viel Gutes, also spendet auch viel, auch während der Corona-Zeit ist schon beliebt in Almeria, hat das Stadion modernisiert. Also dort hat er schon noch Kredit. Das ist jetzt nicht so das typische Thema wie zum Beispiel die Scheichs in Malaga oder der Scheich in Malaga, der da auch sehr viel Geld veruntreut hat und sehr viele private Reisen und Luxusgüter sich gekauft hat. Zumindest ist sowas jetzt bei Turkey als Scheich noch nicht rausgekommen, aber wie gesagt, viele Trainer verschlissen eine enorme Fluktuation an Spielern. Da hat man auch mal Glück, dass man mal einen David Nunes entdeckt, den hat ja Almeria aus Uruguay damals geholt, ist lange her. Aber an sich steht jetzt der Verein nicht für das ideale Scouting, sondern wie gesagt, da wird eher mal ein paar gute Spieler zusammen holen, die müssen schon funktionieren und am Ende harmoniert da nichts auf dem Platz. Von dem her ist der Almeria nicht ganz zu unrecht letzter, auch wenn sie hier und da Pech haben in manchen Spielen. Die haben bei Real Madrid mit 2-0 gewonnen, dann hatte Real Madrid 3 sehr, sehr glückliche Schiedsrichterentscheidungen, wo sie dann am Ende noch 3-2 gewonnen haben. Also das war ein sehr wildes Spiel, aber ich glaube, sie haben in den Ligern diese Saison in sechs Spielen geführt und aus diesen sechs Spielen nur einen Punkt geholt und das war nach 3-0 Führung gegen Granada im Hinspiel noch 3 zu 3 zu spielen, also dann noch drei Gegentore Kassetti sind da einfach defensiv, Hanebüchen teilweise, wie gesagt größte Schießbude der Liga mit 52 Gegentoren.
52 Gegentore, das ist schon wirklich, ich meine 25 Spiele, klar, aber trotzdem. Also ich habe noch mal gerade nachgeguckt, es ging damals darum, dass der Investor eingestiegen ist, also sprich von dir und dass es damals da eine Euphorie gab und wir haben darüber gesprochen, warum das durchaus auch kritisch zu sehen ist. Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass wir Investoren kritisch gesehen haben, in meinem Rasenfunk. Aber das war 2019, 2024 hat sich natürlich das krass geändert. Wie ist denn das für dich, wenn du versuchst, bei so einem Team wie Almeria dran zu bleiben, ist es einfach von Deutschland aus, quasi auch Spiele von denen zu sehen oder zumindest Zusammenfassungen zu bekommen?
Ja, Desson überträgt ja die Spiele, auch wenn dann meistens nur ein englischer Kommentator ist. Ja, Desson überträgt alle La-Liga-Partien. Ansonsten sind natürlich jetzt, wenn man jetzt primär, wie ich in die Marker und Ass liest, sind da jetzt nicht ganz viele Medien. Das haben ja teilweise noch auch Valencia Sevilla, haben ja auch nochmal eigene Nachrichten, Häuser, aber Almeria ist da jetzt trotzdem eher eine kleinere Nummer und wie schon eben beim Investoren-Protest-Thema angedeutet, der ganz große Protest gegen Investoren ist jetzt in Spanien nicht da oder noch nicht da, zumindest nicht in Almeria. Das war jetzt in Malaga natürlich nochmal eine andere Nummer. Deswegen ist da jetzt rund um den Verein, kriegt man gar nicht so viel mit. Im Endeffekt warten alle darauf, dass jetzt doch nochmal der Trainer wechselt, also da der dritte Trainer in dieser Saison bei Almeria kommt. Aber irgendwas scheinen Alshayk und Garry Tarnow da scheinbar gemeinsam zu haben, deswegen der sich immer noch halten kann. Aber es ist ja trotzdem auch fast schon ein bisschen hoffnungslos, auch wenn 12 Punkte aufs rettende Ufer nicht so mega viel sind für noch 14 Spieltage, glaube ich. Aber die Mannschaft sendet einfach sehr wenig positive Signale aus, hat kein Spielglück und deswegen ist da Almeria fast schon ein bisschen abgeschrieben und findet in den Medien nicht so statt. Deswegen war ich mal ganz happy, dass wir hier mit reinzubringen.
Ja, finde ich auch sehr, sehr gut. Und vor allem passt es auch ganz wunderbar, weil wir wollen auch in der Serie A auf den Abstiegskampf blicken. Da bekommen wir nämlich ein Positiv- und ein Negativbeispiel von Marius präsentiert. Wobei, wir müssen eigentlich fast mit dem Negativbeispiel ja dann beginnen. Das baut ja dann die Brücke zu Almeria. Leg mal los, Marius.
Genau, da gibt es den Tabellenletzten US-Salernitana, der zumindest in meiner Bubble jetzt Anfang Februar vor allem mit dem meiner Meinung nach schlimmsten Transfer der Saison aufgefallen ist mit der Verpflichtung von Jerome Boateng. Und folgerichtig hat man auch mit Boateng noch kein Spiel gewonnen. Und mittlerweile auch den Trainer gewechselt. Der Verein spielt seit er aufgestiegen ist fast konstant gegen den Abstieg. Mal ein bisschen souveräner, mal knapper. Und eigentlich zieht sich das durch, dass im Winter der halbe Kader ausgetauscht wurde. Das ist auch jetzt der Fall gewesen. Und man hat versucht, das altbewährte Mittel, wir holen ein paar 33-jährige Recken und damit klappt das dann irgendwie zu nutzen. Also die Innenverteidigung besteht jetzt aus Federico Fasio, den Uli glaube ich noch aus Tottenham kennt, wenn er dabei ist, Boateng eben und Kostas Manolas, der vorher ein halbes Jahr vereinslos war. Das ist jetzt die Verteidigung, die den Klassenerhalt besorgen soll. Dann ist aber der Trainer Pipo Enzagi, das ist auch der zweite in dieser Saison, der ist entlassen worden, nachdem er überraschenderweise ganz unerfolgreich war. Der hatte von Paulus Rosa übernommen. BVB-Fans werden sich erinnern. Und jetzt haben sie gerade Fabio Livarani vorgestellt als Trainer und der hat den sensationellen Serie A Track-Record von 61 Spielen und 0, 84 Punkten im Schnitt.
Das ist ja noch unter Klinsmann Schreck strich Tuchel.
Ich kenne ihn gut, weil er auch mal bei Parma-Trainer war, nachdem er eigentlich in Lecce interessante Arbeit zumindest geleistet hat. Also der hat damit berauschend im Offensivfußball den Aufstieg mit Lecce geschafft, ist dann nach Parma gekommen und hat mit seinem Hurra-Fußball dann ganze zwei Spiele gewonnen. Entsprechend ist das das, was man erwartet. Eine Mannschaft, die eigentlich Probleme in der Defensive hat, holt einen Trainer, der für Offensivfußball steht und damit in der zweiten Liga immer ganz gut gefahren ist. Aber sobald er in der ersten Liga war, komplett ausgecoacht wurde. Das sind so die smarten Entscheidungen im Abstiegskampf. Deswegen da hier als mein Negativbeispiel. Im Gegensatz…
Warte noch ganz kurz. Das interessiert mich jetzt doch. Hat den Salernitana irgendwie darauf reagiert auf die Reaktionen zumindest vieler deutscher Fußballfans, die ich gesehen habe? Bei Twitter war es ganz krass, dass du eigentlich nur Rest in Peace Kasia Leonhardt unter der Verpflichtung gelesen hast. Bei Instagram weiß ich nicht, ob sie moderiert haben oder es da weniger Leute geschrieben haben. Gab es da irgendeine Reaktion drauf?
Also hat keine Rolle gespielt. Auch von daher… Ich gönne dem Verein den Abstieg.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt keinen Mitleid haben. Genau, würde ich auch sagen. Also dann macht mal weiter so. Aber wir haben ja auch noch ein Positivbeispiel.
Genau. Und das ist der FC Empoli, der auch seinen dritten Trainer in der Saison hat. Nach Paolo Zanetti und Andrea Andrea Zoli haben sie Davide Nicola geholt. Und ich glaube, über den habe ich in der Ligatur auch schon mal referiert. Und zwar als der Trainer wiederum der Salenitana war. Denn das ist der absolute Klassenerhaltsmagier in der Serie A. Also wenn der einen Verein übernimmt, dann kann man sich im Grunde genommen darauf verlassen, dass die es packen. Also der hat mit Crotone sensationell den Klassenerhalt geschafft. Dann hat er mit Salenitana, nachdem die glaube ich nach der Hinrunde nur sieben Punkte hatten oder so, hat er den Klassenerhalt noch geschafft. Und jetzt ist er in Empoli. Sie haben fünf Spiele gespielt, zwei gewonnen, drei unentschieden. Also seit fünf Spielen ohne Niederlage haben sie sich zum ersten Mal, ich glaube seit dem 13. Spieltag oder so überhaupt aus den Abstiegsringen verabschiedet. Und da waren Gegner wie Fiorentina Juve oder eben Salenitana der direkte Rivale. Das ist smart und deswegen wird auch Empoli den Klassenerhalt schaffen.
Und also er ist quasi der Felix Maggert, der ist ja ja, wenn sonst keiner sagt, dann muss ich es sagen.
Oder Jörg Berger vielleicht.
Oder Jörg Berger. Ja, eine noch viel schönere Referenz. Ich denke, das 1 zu 1 gegen Juve werden manche mitbekommen haben, weil Juve ja unter anderem deswegen jetzt auch ganz schön abreißen hat lassen müssen gegenüber Inter. Kann man denn auch sagen, mit welchen Methoden er das hinbekommt? Geht es da auch so über die Physik? Ist er ein perfekter Mentaltrainer, so wie Gattuso?
Er hat vielleicht im Vergleich zu – also wenn man es jetzt gerade mit Insagi vorher vergleicht, der auch so gut er als Spieler war, leider kein sonderlich guter Serie-A-Trainer bisher in seiner Laufbahn gewesen ist, also bei allen Vereinen eigentlich gescheitert ist – einen viel klareren Matchplan, der natürlich, wie sich das dann für Abstiegskampf gehört, erst mal darauf beruht, die Defensive zu festigen, mit einem Mittelfeld davor, das sehr kompakt steht und dann im Grunde schnelle Verlagerungen über außen in die Spitze und also relativ schnörkellos, das zu Ende spielt und nicht zu viel versuchen, Ich würde es nicht versuchen, sondern einfach relativ straight, das so quasi hinzubiegen. Das klingt jetzt irgendwie auch unspektakulär, aber ist es ja im Grunde genommen auch.
Ja, compact stehen, schnell umschalten.
Genau.
Das ist natürlich, das wird in den Fußballkanonen eingehen. Als die Nicolataktik.
Genau. Aber es funktioniert offensichtlich immer wieder. Er muss ein Magier sein, denn auch wenn es eigentlich einfach ausrechenbar sein sollte, ist es das offensichtlich nicht.
Markus Gistol. Er ist der Markus Gistol, der ist ja hier ab. Das Gistol-Miracle. Jetzt auch bei Empoli. Stark, stark. Also Empoli und Salah Nitana. Sehr schön, dass wir mal auf den Abstiegskampf geblickt haben. Und für alle diejenigen, die die Tabelle nicht vor Augen haben, so wie ich. Dann die Ergänzung noch. Kaliari ist auf dem vorletzten Platz. Sassuolo mit 20 Punkten auf dem drittletzten. Hellas Verona auf dem viertletzten. Und die beiden, die drei trennen nur zwei Punkte. Das heißt Salah Nitana ziemlich weit weg. Empoli ist jetzt da unten rausgekommen. Und für Verona, Sassuolo und Kaliari ist das keine gute Nachricht. Denn die stecken jetzt unten drin. Aber es ist eng da unten. Frau Sinone, Udinese auch noch nicht weg. Also da bin ich mal gespannt, was da noch passiert. Und dann freue ich mich sehr, dass unsere Runde größer geworden ist. Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier. Schön, dass du es geschafft hast, lieber Uli. Hi.
Der zweitschlechteste Transfer der Saison.
Ach komm, so ein Quatsch. Wir sind beim Rasenfunk einfach froh, dass wir noch Neuzugänge registrieren dürfen, dass es uns nicht geht wegen dem ersten FC Köln. Uns ist man noch nicht auf die Schliche gekommen. Uli, schön, dass du da bist. Ganz am Anfang haben wir kurz darüber gesprochen, über die Fan-Proteste in der Bundesliga und ob das in den anderen Ligen wahrgenommen wurde und da etwas Ähnliches auch denkbar wäre. Das interessiert mich bei der Premier League und ist ehrlich gesagt auch.
Es gab Reaktionen, mich haben ein paar Kollegen angerufen und gesagt, was ist eigentlich los, wo ist das Problem? Weil es in England ja völlig normal ist logischerweise, dass Investoren schon seit 114 Jahren da sind, sowohl in den Vereinen als auch in der Liga logischerweise. Also die hat ja schon einen Beinamen etc. Das heißt, die Engländer verstehen, also ich kriege den Anruf auch jährlich, wenn irgendein englisches Team gegen Leipzig spielt, dass irgendjemand fragt, wo ist ja der Problem mit dem Namen Leipzig und dem Konstrukt? Und wenn ich das denen dann erkläre, wie zum Teil dann das dazu kam und so, dann verstehen sie es einigermaßen. Aber alles in allem herrscht da große Verwunderung darüber. Es ist in Teilen berichtet worden, aber ich will nicht sagen, Oberflächlich, ja doch, sagen wir so, recht oberflächlich. Aber ich meine, das ist ja das eine und das andere Medium auch mit deutschsprachigem Content.
Ja, und das ist in anderen Ligen, also bei Lequip war es auf Seite 10, hat uns David noch rausgesucht. Also das ist jetzt alles kein Problem.
Ja, es hielt sich in Grenzen tatsächlich.
Und dann weiß ich ja Uli, dass du uns immer ein positiv und ein weniger positives Thema mitbringst. Nachdem wir jetzt gerade aus dem Abstiegskampf kommen, würde ich sagen, wollen wir mit dem weniger positiven bei dir starten?
Ich würde es nicht sagen gerne, weil bei negativen sagt man ja nicht gerne. Aber ja, ich habe mir heute mal überlegt, es gibt ja die Rasenfunk-Ligatour-Gesetzmäßigkeit bei mir, dass ich versuche zu überlegen, was habe ich noch nicht erzählt. Also ich will nicht so gerne mit den immer gleichen Teams aufwarten. Und ich glaube, wir hatten als so ziemlich einziges Team noch gar nicht, also nicht Brentford. Bei den anderen kann ich jetzt nicht 100% schweren, aber ich glaube, das hatten wir noch nicht. Und die sind mir jetzt vor allen Dingen ergebnistechnisch negativ aufgefallen, haben jetzt 8 der letzten 10 Spiele verloren, haben seit Anfang Dezember eine echt schwierige Phase. Zum zweiten Mal kommt es jetzt so, dass der Spielplan das nicht sehr gut meint mit ihnen. Das ist Punkt Nummer 1. Punkt Nummer 2 ist aber, dass sie einfach im Moment nicht so gut sind, wie sie es normalerweise waren. In aller Regel hat Brentford immer fast automatisch gegen die sogenannten Big Six gepunktet, weil die denen einen ganz besonderen Match planen. Er hat Thomas Frank jetzt auch nochmal vor dem Liverpool-Spiel – also Liverpool hat ja gestern nochmal gewonnen gegen Luten – aber vor dem Liverpool-Spiel am Wochenende nochmal gesagt, dass sie genau das tun. Sie stehen dann nochmal etwas passiver, versuchen dann nochmal etwas schneller ins Umschalten zu kommen, versuchen ganz oft – also das ist jetzt wiederum meine Lesart, das hat er so nicht gesagt, aber das ist das, was meine Analyse ergeben hat, dass sie versuchen, die Netto-Spielzeit unten zu halten, viel Rhythmus stören, Balance ausklopfen, kleinere Foul-Spiels anhängen, ohne ungefähr zu rennen.
Moment mal, Uli, das kann gar nicht sein. So spielen doch nur Italiener, wenn ich deutschen Medien glaube. Das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Der Cartenaccio.
Ja, das ist er.
Stehen nur hinten drin. Ja, genau, so ist es. Dafür kriegen sie aber jetzt echt viele Gegentore. Jetzt klingt der Wecker, dass ich zu dir kommen sollte in der Rasenfunk.
Bist wie immer deiner Zeit voraus.
Sie kriegen viele Gegentore, sind im Umschalten nach hinten schwach, haben jetzt ein paar Verletzte auch gehabt, wovon sie dann einfach Schwierigkeiten haben, den ein oder anderen zu ersetzen. Bimo vor allen Dingen in der Offensive waren jetzt zwei Spieler beim African Cup of Nations, die einfach sehr gefehlt haben aufgrund ihrer Intensität. Sie haben defensiv – also die Gegentore gibt es, weil sie zum Teil einfach im Mannschaftstaktischen nicht funktionieren, zum anderen Teil, weil sie sich komische individuelle Fehler leisten. Die Leute, die sie verpflichtet haben, sie sind im Grunde genommen im Kern beieinander geblieben, so wie sie aufgestiegen sind, mit 1, 2, 3 Additionen, aber wirklich ganz, ganz fein was getan. Und von denen, die gekommen sind, die sind entweder verletzt oder helfen nicht ernsthaft weiter. Collins ist so ein Negativbeispiel, der in der Verteidigung nicht richtig reinkommt. Dafür haben sie, wie ich finde, recht wenig auch noch im Winter reagiert. Das tun sie traditionell nicht. Jetzt haben sie sogar mal was gemacht, aber keine Spieler, die sofort helfen. Reguillon, den wird Nils noch ganz gut kennen, ist nie wieder derjenige geworden, der mal war bei Atletico. Der hatte diese eine richtig gute Saison. Ich glaube, bei Real war es auch okay, soweit ich das notiert habe.
Bei Sevilla war es richtig gut.
Bei Sevilla war es nicht Atletico, sorry. Aber in England, weder bei United, wo er die erste Halbserie leihweise gespielt hat, irgendwas gezeigt, noch bei Tottenham. Und es sieht auch nicht so richtig gut aus, wenn ich ehrlich bin, bei Brentford. Die kommen jetzt in ein Programm ein. Puh, muss ich jetzt nochmal nachschauen, dass ich nichts falsches erzähle. Die haben jetzt noch Chelsea, Manchester United, dann Brighton, Manchester City, dann Westhams, was schon durchatmen, Arsenal und Eston Villa. Das heißt, die könnten dann so 6, 7 Spieltage vor Schluss echt drin hängen, wenn das Bild läuft.
Und wie machen sich die Freiburger? Ich nehme David die Frage einfach aus dem Bund.
Ja, das ist echt ganz seltsam. Der ist verletzt. Seit er da ist, hat er immer mal wieder gezeigt, vergangenes Saison in der Rückrunde, ja, kann da reinpassen. Ein schneller Spieler hat aber 0, 0 Effizienz gezeigt, dass er im Moment ausschließlich verletzt. Und Marc Flecken hatte echt Probleme zu Beginn der Saison. Ist nicht David Reier, kommt jetzt langsam besser rein. Da waren jetzt ein paar Spiele dabei. Der war wirklich ein absoluter Retter, hat auch den Rekord von der meisten abgewährten Bälle in einem Spiel in der Premier League in der laufenden Saison. Hat aber auch Spiele, wo man denkt, boah, ne, also gewinnen tust du nichts. Und sie sind auch nicht so glücklich mit Flecken tatsächlich in Brentford, wie sie dachten, dass sie es werden. Aber er folgt halt auch auf David Reier, der schon echt gut war.
Vielleicht auch wieder das Beispiel, haben wir schon ganz oft gesehen, dass Freiburger Torhüter woanders sich zumindest erst mal schwer tun. Freiburg spielt da einfach auch ein bisschen besonders, glaube ich, in der ganzen Art und Weise, wie man verteidigt. Jetzt ist Brentford ja aufgestiegen 2021 und jetzt quasi im dritten Erstliga-Jahr. Was, und wir haben schon ein paar Mal über Brentford gesprochen, eben wegen Thomas Frank, wegen des Ansatzsystems hat und weil sie eben der Stolperstein für die Big Six sind. Also sie haben indirekt schon ganz oft im Meisterspiel und im Meisterschaftsrennen mitgespielt. Was würde denn der Premier League verloren gehen, sollte das Brentford in diesem Jahr nicht schaffen und wieder runtergehen?
Einer der bestgeführten Vereine in Europa, würde ich behaupten, mit dem ersten Team, das diesen stark datenzentrierten Scouting-Ansatz verfolgt hat. Ein Team, das eine riesengroße Historie hat, also höchst traditionell auch in England ist, sehr eigen irgendwie immer noch, also den Spagat gerade macht von dem absolut kleinen Verein, der gibt es immer so, den schönen Satz, das ist nur ein Busstopp im Harnsloch, hin zu einem weltweit Operierenden. Da sind wir schließlich wieder auf der Suche nach neuen Investoren, Matthew Bannham, der wirklich bei Moneyball seine Finger mit drin hat. Es wird ja immer ganz gerne so gesagt, wenn datenorientiert gescoutet wird, ist Moneyball. Aber in dem Fall ist es wirklich so, dass er tatsächlich da seine Finger mit drin hatte. Und das würde schon fehlen, finde ich. Also der historische Teil, das hat noch so ein kleines Stückchen englische Idylle in diesem riesengroßen Premier League-Ding. Das wäre schon schade. Und halt dann, je nachdem, aber der Manager, der schon auch irgendwie besonders ist, die hatten jetzt ihr 100. Premier League-Spiel am Wochenende gegen Liverpool und da ist die Kamera ganz nah an Thomas Frank herangefahren und da hat man so leichte Feuchtigkeit in den Augen vernehmen können, obwohl jetzt die Stimmung überhaupt nicht nach 100. Premier League-Spiel aussah oder sich angehört hätte. Aber ich glaube schon, dass ihm klar ist, was sie da gepackt haben seitdem der da ist. Der hat fast die erste Woche gar nicht überlebt, weil er einfach fürchterlich verloren hat. Er hat überhaupt nicht gewonnen die ersten Monate und ist jetzt dann mit 100 Premier League-Spielen da. Das ist ihm glaube ich klar. Ich habe auch kurz überlegt, ob ich das zum Moment machen soll. Aber wenn man sich das im Nachhinein angucken würde, würde man sich wahrscheinlich denken, es ist halt einfach nur dieses eine kurze Tränchen, das er da vergießt. Aber ansonsten sieht und hört man halt nichts über das 100 Premier League-Spiel.
Und wir wissen ja, das machen alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen, dass sie dann sofort die Momente nochmal gegenchecken. Du bist einfach das Special One, Uli. Also Brandford, 5 Punkte Forschung sind das aktuell. Ganz hartes Programm kommt. Aber wir werden mal sehen, wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass ein Brandford überrascht. Das muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Vielleicht schafft man ja dann den Turnaround. Und wir schaffen den Turnaround jetzt dahingehend, dass wir in die positiveren Themen springen. Und völlig überraschend, David, können wir da über Lyon sprechen. Hä? Moment, was?
Ja, genau, wir sind eigentlich auch im Abstiegskampf. Oder wir wären im Abstiegskampf gewesen. Ich hatte Lyon Anfang der Saison schon mal vorgestellt als absolutes Negativbeispiel. Und das hat sich auch so fortgesetzt. Die waren Ende November fünf Punkte vom Nichtabschied entfernt, Rock Bottom da irgendwie unten an der Tabelle rinnen. Es sah nicht danach aus, als würde da irgendwie noch mal was gehen. Ja, und jetzt haben sie plötzlich einen dritten Sieg in Folge gemacht. Haben von den letzten acht Ligaspielen seit Mitte Dezember 6 gewonnen. Dazu noch Lille aus dem Pokal geworfen, die auch gar nicht so schlecht die Saison spielen und stehen da komfortabel auf Rang 11 herum. Das hätte ich tatsächlich auch nicht gedacht, muss ich sagen. Wir erinnern uns auch da, im September waren auch Blanc entlassen worden. Dann kam Fabio Grosso an Bord. Der ist mittlerweile auch weg. Also das ist jetzt schon auch der zweite italienische Trainer in der Liga, der nicht funktioniert hat diese Saison. Farioli bei Nizza ist noch da. Grosso ist durch Pierre Sage ersetzt worden, ehemaliger Leiter des Ausbildungszentrums, 44 Jahre. Der hat dann zu seinem Amtsantritt den Spielern empfohlen, sie sollen doch jetzt mal gefährlichst aufhören, Cello zu spielen, sollen die E-Gitarre auspacken. War vorher noch nie Chef-Trainer, aber hat das jetzt bemerkenswert gut hinbekommen. Man muss allerdings auch sagen, der Transfermarkt hat ihm auch ein bisschen geholfen. Also ich hatte ja vorhin das Beispiel mit Marseille und Gasset und dass der bei Saint-Etienne dann nochmal ein bisschen nachlegen konnte. Also Lyon hat nachgelegt und ich mache jetzt mal ein bisschen Name-Dropping, aber einfach nur damit wir mal die Dimensionen auch mit dem Geld hinbekommen. Vofana und Gift Orban kamen zusammen für 29 Millionen aus Rennes. Adrielsan und Ersatzverwalt Perry kamen für 7 Millionen gemeinsam aus Botafogo. Matic kam für 3 Millionen aus Rennes. Ben Rama wurde für 6 Millionen von West Ham geliehen und Mangala für 12 Millionen aus Nottingham. Mangala ist übrigens genau derjenige, den wir aus Stuttgart kennen. Das macht zusammen – ich habe es kurz überschlagen – ungefähr 57 Millionen Euro. Das ist jetzt auch nicht das Geld, was sich jeder Club auf dem Abstiegsrang so leisten kann, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe jetzt auch mal einfach zum Vergleich auf Transfermarkt geschaut, wie die da so die Marktwerte einschätzen. Von den Top 6 waren es, glaube ich, mit den höchst eingeschätzten Marktwerten sind jetzt drei Neuzugänge dabei. Also die einzigen langfristigen Talente aus Lyon sind Scherky und Kakere. Wobei – witzigerweise – auf Platz 7 kommt dann noch Lacazette, auch wenn der fünf Jahre bei Arsenal war und mittlerweile 32 Jahre alt ist. Der ist ja auch ein Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend. Da haben wir nicht vergessen, das ist ja auch ein Spieler aus Arsenal. Also davon standen jetzt auch eine ganze Reihe auf dem Platz gegen Nizza. Gift Orban wurde eingewechselt. Gift Orban hatte Alexi schon mal erwähnt.
Genau, der hatte das auch prophezeit. Er hat gesagt, es war der beste Transfer des Winters.
Genau. Also es war kein herausragendes Spiel jetzt am Wochenende gegen Nizza. Aber Tor fiel dann durch einen schnellen, weiten Abschlag vom Torwart. Dann hatten die Lyons zehn Minuten Oberwasser. Das war es irgendwie auch schon, aber es hat gereicht. 1 zu 0 gegen Nizza. Die sind immerhin zweitplatzierter gewesen. Das war noch ein bisschen unerwartet. Hat auch Nizza sehr wehgetan. Hat auch dem Titelkampf sehr wehgetan, weil sämtliche Hoffnungen, die man glaube ich irgendwie noch haben hätte können. Also halbwegs sind jetzt definitiv weg. Also Paris ist 11 Punkte vor Nizza und 10 Punkte vor dem neuen zweitplatzierten Brest. Du wirst mich wahrscheinlich gleich fragen, was macht denn – was hat denn – jetzt wollte ich wieder Gassel sagen. Nein, Quatsch. Was hat Saj anders gemacht? Was er anders gemacht hat, ist keine Angst mehr vor Lang und Weit, so ein bisschen auch. Also auch da wieder ein bisschen simpler. Das Spiel ist athletischer geworden. Statistiken für Laufleistungen und lange Sprints sind nach oben gegangen. Sie haben auf Anraten von Saj auch einen Freistoß-Spezialisten ins Team geholt. Ganz kreative Lösung, sage ich hier als Freiburger, ist lösend. Und verwandeln jetzt tatsächlich 40 Prozent ihrer Standards auch in Torschüsse. Das sah unter großer noch deutlich aus.
40 Prozent?
Genau. Wer durchaus auffällig war am Wochenende zum wiederholten Mal, war der 20-jährige Ghanaische Nationalspieler Nuama. Und falls da was klingelt bei euch, das war dieser Spieler, der im Sommer für diese fragwürdige Transferpause verantwortlich war, der vom belgischen Club Möhlenbeck für 25 Stunden gekauft worden ist und danach Lyon verliehen würde, weil ja beide demselben Konglomerat angehören von John Textor und seiner Eagle Football Holding. Da hat jetzt gerade anscheinend, habe ich gelesen, die FIFA entschieden, dass der Transfer mit rechten Dingen zuging. Das Ding ist jetzt anscheinend erstmal durch.
Aber gut, ich meine, die UE verstellt sich auch nicht gegen Multiclub-Ownership. Die finden das alle nicht so schlimm. Also ist es wohl einfach so.
Genau. Und für Lyon geht es jetzt am Freitag gegen Metz. Die haben aktuell 5 Punkte auf den Relegationsplatz. Wenn sie jetzt Metz nicht wieder rankommen lassen, würde ich sagen, dann ist zumindest der direkte Abstieg in weiter Ferne. Da rund um den Relegationsplatz knubbelt es sich ein bisschen. Aber das ist eine Entwicklung, die ich tatsächlich so nicht gesehen hätte, muss ich sagen.
Tja, Lyon. Nicht schlecht. Und Lyon jetzt auch wieder gut nach Standards. Ich werde jetzt nicht zum 800.000. Mal die Referenz aus meiner Jugend bringen, aber alle, die da mal Fußball geguckt haben oder vor allem an der Konsole gespielt haben. Die wissen genau, was da klingelt. Sehr, sehr schön. Wir haben noch, Nils, ein ganz kleines Thema aus La Liga. Wir sind eingestiegen vorhin mit Investoren und so weiter und dem Verhältnis dazu. Und jetzt wollen wir mal über den Salary Cap sprechen. Was gibt es denn da Neues?
Neu ist jetzt, dass La Liga nach den Transferphasen immer wieder die Gehaltsobergrenzen anpasst, die neuen Zahlen auch transparent veröffentlicht mit Artikeln und weiteren Infos. Und das macht ja La Liga jetzt seit der Saison 19, 20 schon. Und an sich würde ich sagen, ist der Ansatz ja auch ok. Also worum geht es darum? Es geht darum, dass Vereine nicht mehr ausgeben, als sie einnehmen, was ja schon mal vernünftig ist, damit die Vereine nicht noch mehr in finanzielle Schieflage geraten, was ja speziell in Spanien, wo viele Vereine enorm überschuldet waren oder teilweise auch noch sind. Deswegen ist der Ansatz ganz gut. Blöd ist natürlich, dass andere Ligen da nicht mitziehen. Deswegen ist immer der Vorwurf, dass sich La Liga da selbst ins eigene Bein schneidet und dann eben weniger Top-Spieler kommen oder Vereine nicht das zahlen können wie andere Top-Vereine. Aber gut, jetzt wurden die Zahlen wieder aktualisiert nach der Winter-Transfer-Phase. Was hat sich da so ergeben? Die Top 4 sind immer noch die gleichen, die ja Madrid bleibt. Nicht nur sportlich, auch finanziell. Natürlich der Spitzenreiter La Liga mit einem Gehaltsvolumen von 727 Millionen Euro, was sie ausgeben dürfen. Das ist viel. Vor allem, wenn man dann anschaut, was so der zweite und der dritte haben. Der zweite ist Atletico, leichter Zuwachs von 296 auf 303 Millionen Euro, also Real immer noch das Doppelte. Und Barca war, bleibt weiter, dritter, wurde nur nochmal abgestuft von 270 auf 204 Millionen Euro, was sie an Geld ausgeben dürfen.
Das heißt, über 500 Millionen weniger als Real. Und ganz kurz zum Vergleich, Bayern hat einen Personalaufwand für alles, also Spiele und so weiter, von 400 Millionen. Also quasi Barca liegt mehr als ein Bayern hinter Real.
Jetzt kommt dann der Widerspruch mit der Realität, weil es heißt, dass eigentlich Barca einen Kader hat, der auch 400 Millionen Euro hat. Und das ist auch nicht nur der Kader, es ist eigentlich der gesamte Verein mit Mitarbeitern, Trainern, ich glaube sogar die Frauenmannschaften und die Jugendmannschaften und alles. Also das ist schon alles, was dahinter steckt. Aber jetzt wurden die Zahlen angepasst und Barca hat eigentlich einen deutlich höheren Kader. Jetzt weiß man nicht, gibt das jetzt Strafen oder was sind da jetzt die Folgen? Es waren ja schon die letzten Jahre immer die Sachen, wo dann die Hebel, sorry Uli, die Palankas gesetzt wurden, von wegen, wir holen uns jetzt schnelles Geld, veräußern Teile unseres Vereins oder treten auch 10 Prozent unserer TV-Rechte ab und kriegen dafür jetzt schon mal die 100 Millionen, verkaufen Barca Studios, was mehrfach geschehen ist. Da haben sie dann eben vor zwei Jahren, konnten sie sich noch da ihre Gehaltsobergrenze auf über 600 Millionen steigern wieder. Da sind sie jetzt eben wieder runtergefallen, weil jetzt dieses schnelle Geld wieder fehlt und weil auch manche Zahlungen ausgeblieben sind. Ich glaube, da gab es Barca Studios, wurde eigentlich verkauft an eine Firma, die heißt Libero, glaube ich, aber da kam das Geld nicht. Auch deswegen jetzt diese Herabstufung von 270 auf 200 Millionen Euro. Also das ist immer einerseits spannend zu sehen, dass da la Liga eben mal transparente Zahlen zeigt, auch wenn man nicht genau weiß, wie genau diese zusammenkommen. Wie gesagt, der Grundgedanke, den finde ich gut, dass Vereine nicht mehr ausgeben, als sie einnehmen. Aber ja, so richtige Folgen, Konsequenzen gibt es nicht, weil theoretisch können ja die Vereine trotzdem drüber liegen wie jetzt Barca, quasi das Doppeltaub, ob es dann wirklich Strafen gibt oder Konsequenzen, ob das jetzt sportlich ist oder finanzieller Natur. Da muss man dann bestimmt abwarten, was dann im Sommer passiert. Da ist ja jetzt Barca quasi noch mehr zum Sparen gezwungen. Übrigens auch der Sevilla als vierte abgestuft von 168 auf 152 Millionen Euro Budget. Also Kaderpersonal. Muss man mal sehen, wie viele Topstars da jetzt Gehaltskürzungen einnehmen müssen oder verkauft werden müssen. Das dürfte wie jeden Sommer ein sehr spannender Sommer, speziell beim FC Barcelona werden. Wo hingegen bei Real Madrid kann man sagen, da ist scheinbar tatsächlich Platz für einen gewissen Franzosen, aber das Fass will ich jetzt nicht aufmachen.
Aber haben wir dich auch schon erlebt, welche Auswirkungen das konkret hat? Also klar, man könnte jetzt quasi noch nachträglich bestraft werden, dass man in dieser Saison drüber liegt, aber solange man drüber liegt, darf man doch keine neuen Spieler registrieren. War das nicht das Vorgehen bisher?
Genau, das ist das Vorgehen immer auch gewesen. Speziell im Sommer haben da viele Vereine auch Bettys, die dann erst am letzten Deadline-Day 4, 5 oder 6 Spieler doch noch eintragen konnten, speziell Neuzugänge oder Spieler, die gerade frisch ihren Vertrag verlängert haben, also wo es auch zu Gehaltserhöhungen kam, dass da viele Vereine Probleme haben, die Spieler zu registrieren. Schlussendlich schaffen es trotzdem alle klar, weil auch da noch mal einer abgegeben wird oder dann wird doch noch einer als Jugendspieler gemeldet. Da gibt es schon viele Tricks, speziell wenn man sich natürlich auch Leihspieler holt, wo dann teilweise das Gehalt noch vom Stammverein abgegeben wird. Oder bei Joao Felix gab es den Trick zum Beispiel, der wurde für einen Mini-Gehalt unter Vertrag genommen, also von Athletico zu Barca ausgeliehen. 400.000 Euro, glaube ich, Gehalt. Das hat dann noch ins Salary Cap damals gepasst. Und dann einen Monat später, als das Salary Cap veröffentlicht wurde, heißt es auf einmal, ja, der hat so gute Leistung, wir verzehnfachen jetzt sein Gehalt. Da kam die Gehaltserhöhung.
Ja, Salary Cap funktioniert auf die lange Dauer. Nie hat er in der Bundesliga nicht funktioniert. Hat noch in keiner Liga wirklich funktioniert, außer man hat eben ein geschlossenes System wie NFL und so weiter. Und selbst da ist es ja so, dass die Art und Weise, wie der noch oben, dann gibt es das ein bisschen Einschränk. Aber jetzt wissen wir endlich, was den 1. FC Köln mit Barca verbindet. Oder natürlich andersrum. Beide können im Sommer keine Spieler registrieren. Ja, aber interessant. Und vor allem die Zahlen zu hören, ist wirklich interessant. Weil es macht ja, ich finde, wenn man das so quasi so live in Anführungszeichen bekommt, während der laufenden Saison, das ist halt ein super Hintergrund, den man neben die aktuelle Tabelle legen kann. Weil eben der Personalaufwand halt schon mit Tabellenplatzierung korreliert zumindest grob. Und wenn man dann sieht, ich meine, jetzt ist real 6 Punkte weg von Girona. Haben wir ja auch schon thematisiert. Dann sieht man ja, okay, das sollte aber halt auch so sein. Ansonsten anderperformen die sehr deutlich. Und bei anderen wiederum sieht man, die machen mehr aus ihren aktuellen Möglichkeiten. Und das finde ich gut. Das finde ich besser, als irgendwie immer mit einem Jahr Verzögerung die Zahlen von der DFL zu bekommen, aus der man dann aber ganz viele Dinge gar nicht so wirklich rauslesen kann.
Kann man, muss ich bestimmt auch an der Stelle dann mal loben. Alaves und Las Palmas haben mit das kleinste Budget, aber sind eben als beste Aufsteiger auf den Plätzen 9, Las Palmas und 12. Alaves, die spielen beide eine super Saison, sind heimstark und so weiter. Unangenehm spielerisch, aber trotzdem auch gut, ohne dass sie jetzt nur mauern. Also die machen viel draus. Und weil du Girona angesprochen hast, ich glaube, die haben mit, was waren es, 42 Millionen Budget, das ist auch unter den letzten 5 Plätzen. Ja, die überperformen halt natürlich, weil sie, wie gesagt, hier und da ein paar Leihspiele haben, wo sie nicht so viel Gehalt zahlen müssen.
Ja, wobei sie ansonsten ganz gut finanziell aufgestellt sein sollen. Da hat Swiss Ramble neulich die Finanzanalyse zugepostet, also 46 Prozent gehören der Citigroup, dann irgendwie 17 Prozent des Vereins gehören dem Bruder von Pep Guardiola, der ja quasi da unterwegs ist. Und aber ganz viel von den Einnahmen, die sie haben, kommen eben aus Sponsoring und so weiter. Also sie arbeiten quasi auf einem gesunden wirtschaftlichen Level und bekommen dann dazu natürlich noch sportliche Qualität von City. Das würde ich jetzt auch kritisieren. Aber es ist jetzt quasi nicht so, dass sie quasi so komplett künstlich hochgezogen würden, sondern die agieren schon relativ vernünftig in einem wirtschaftlichen Rahmen.
Und auch da haben wir auch gute Scout-Diggen mit Atendorfbeg, das wird auch viel Gutes gemacht.
Also wirklich ganz interessant. Und Las Palmas, das haben vielleicht einige mitbekommen, die haben Real doch so ein gutes Heimspiel geliefert. War das nicht relativ knapp, dass Real da gewonnen hat? Zwei, eins, genau, erst hinten raus.
Ja, auch nach Rückstand mal wieder.
Genau, genau, aber gut, das ist ja für Real egal und läuft ja eh alles.
Erst dann wird es spannend.
Ja, ja, komm, erst ab Champions-League-Finale wird es interessant. Das wird ja quasi die Saison eines Realtrainers, das wird ja nach dem Abschneiden im Champions-League-Finale bewertet. Deswegen müssen wir da noch ein bisschen warten. Also das ist der neue Salary Cap in La Liga. Und bevor wir zu den Awards kommen, schauen wir nochmal in die Premier League. Uli, was magst du uns da noch als zweites Thema präsentieren?
Ich glaube, das zweite ist einigermaßen naheliegend. Oliver Glasner, wir haben ja schon mal ganz kurz von der Gruppe gehört. Aber das ist, glaube ich, sehr naheliegend. Das ist jetzt nicht zwingend positiv. Das heißt, ich breche mit meiner auferlegten Idee, wobei ich es dann doch irgendwie sehr positiv finde für Crystal Palace. Das ist, glaube ich, ein echter Stil, diesen Trainer bekommen zu haben. Und der hat jetzt Dienstag dann seine Dienste aufgenommen, obwohl er schon eine ganze Zeit lang, glaube ich, da war im Süden Londons. Muss man oder kommt man, glaube ich, nicht aus, ohne ein halbes Wort zu Roy Hodgson zu verlieren. Wir haben ja jetzt schon einmal hier über ihn gesprochen und die Gründe, warum das alles gerade nicht so läuft. Jetzt ist er 76, ist am vergangenen Donnerstag auf dem Trainingsplatz zusammengebrochen. Das ist das, was ich weiß. Und der Kollege, der da war, hat mir nur gesagt, es war wirklich so, dass einige echt schockiert waren. Und allein im Sinne der Gesundheit ist es dann vielleicht auch ganz gut, dass er tatsächlich sich jetzt mal eine Ruhepause gönnt. Ich würde noch nicht sagen, dass er seine Trainer-Karriere beendet, weil ich das glaube ich einfach noch nicht. Aber zumindest, dass er jetzt mal für das Erste eine kleine Pause aus gesundheitlichen Gründen dann auch einlegen kann. Absolut verdienter Mann, Meister Premier League-Spieler bei Crystal Palace, kommt ja auch aus dem Borough of Croydon. Das ist immer sein Verein gewesen. Auch deshalb hat er sich noch ein zweites Mal hinreißen lassen, um ihn zu retten. Vielleicht war es dann am Ende ein halbes Jahr zu viel. Da ist er dann auch wieder, der schon genannte John Texter. Der wollte ihn wohl schon im Dezember, als wir hier drüber gesprochen haben, gerne ablösen. Er gab vor allen Dingen Sorge, dass das Training zu wenig intensiv gewesen sei und dass Roy Watson sich selbst hier und da mal im Kopf und Kragen redet. Das hat er jetzt dann final getan. Auch aufgrund der Intensität haben sie dann Oliver Glasner letzten Mittwoch als absoluten Wunschkandidaten ausgemacht. Da hat mich der besagte Kollege ganz hektisch angerufen und gesagt, wir müssen alles zu Glasner sagen. Da habe ich noch gesagt, das wird nie passieren, der geht da nicht hin.
Warum hast du das gedacht?
Weil ich mit ihm ganz lange drüber gesprochen hatte, wie der nächste Club aussehen sollte. Und alles, was er da beschrieben hat, ist nicht Crystal Palace. Das hat mir also sehr gewundert, dass er das dann tatsächlich gemacht hat, auch wenn ich den Reiz natürlich schon verstehen kann.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, dazu gehört vielleicht, dass Uli Glasner mutmaßlich das nicht die erste Möglichkeit war, in die Premier League zu wechseln und der letzte Verein, der da eventuell mit einer Rolle gespielt hat, jetzt aktuell Tabellenvierter ist. Vielleicht spielt das damit rein, dass man das Gefühl hat, jetzt will ich nicht noch eine Möglichkeit verstreichen lassen.
Ja, mir hat auch ein anderer Kollege gesagt, dass er tatsächlich auch bei Nottingham von sich aus schon vorgesprochen haben soll, als die nun Respetto Santo dann genommen hatten anstelle Steve Coopers. Auch das ist nur Mutmaßung, ich weiß das nicht. Habe ich nicht mit ihm darüber gesprochen. Das wäre also jetzt falsch, auch nur in die Entfernung zu gehen. Ich denke, dass sich vielleicht Kemp Glasner insgesamt ausgerechnet haben könnte, dass er vielleicht bei mehr Positionen genannt werden würde für potenzielle Nachfolgen. Mal abgesehen davon, dass es gar nicht so viele dieser Positionen gab in der Saison, die frei geworden wären. Die Champions League-Aspiranten haben gar nicht gewechselt, weder in der Premier League noch auch in der Bundesliga zum Beispiel, wo es irgendwie naheliegend wäre. Ich sage jetzt nochmal, hätte Oliver Glasner sich vielleicht gedacht, Dortmund wäre okay gewesen, vermutlich. Aber die haben halt nicht gewechselt zum Beispiel.
Wer wollte auf Bayern nicht warten?
Wäre auch denkbar, muss man schon ehrlich sagen. Es ist auch eine komische Woche, in der das tatsächlich passiert. Ich glaube, dass man wahrscheinlich gemerkt hat, wir werden nicht so konstant genannt, wenn es Nachfolger suchen gibt, wie wir dachten, dass wir es werden. Wäre wahrscheinlich auch anders gewesen, wenn im letzten Sommer der Europapokal nach Frankfurt gewandert wäre und nicht im Jahr davor. So sind schon einige Red Flags hochgegangen, ob des Verhaltens hinten raus bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Da gab es auch mehrere Nachfragen dazu von einigen Kollegen, die gesagt haben, wie war das exakt. Das ist so meine ganz eigene Herleitung, wie es zu Crystal Palace gekommen ist. Neben dem, dass ich denke, dass er echt einiges an Macht bekommen wird. Vom Status, vom Namen her waren auch die englischen Kollegen echt verwundert, dass der das macht. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, Platz 12 ist das Maximum. Oder 11, keine Ahnung. Aber da muss schon alles ideal laufen. Ich glaube, mehr geht auch nicht.
Ach, krass. Aber er hat vielleicht auch keine andere Wahl als zu Crystal Palace zu gehen. Ich meine, da spielt Cagiro Riedewald und das ist so nah an Frankfurt-Riedewald, da musste er ja hin.
Den finde ich sehr gut, muss ich sagen. Vielleicht als Referenzclown.
Sehr gut. Aber was ist von dem Kader zu erwarten? Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, Stil aus Sicht von Crystal Palace. Gleichzeitig hast du gesagt, also maximal vier Plätze nach oben geht es noch, weil sie sind aktuell 15. Du hast 11 als Dach so ein bisschen angesprochen. Was ist zu erwarten?
Ja, also wie immer, Glasner wird dem Team beibringen, dass sie seriös spielen, wenig zulassen und ins Umschalten gehen. Das ist auch im Grunde das, was Roy Ortschneier auch getan hat. Nur, dass sie jetzt einfach viel zu viele Gegentore kassiert haben. Auch aufgrund von Verletzungen, teilweise die Defensive nicht beieinander hatten. Ich glaube schon, dass da ein paar Spieler drin sind, die Glasner echt mag. Mir fehlt nach wie vor Wilfrid Zaha, der das einzige Outlet war in der letzten Saison. Da hat er schon seinen 4-4-2-Umschalt-Fußball durchziehen können. Der fehlt halt einfach mit seiner Qualität. Den haben sie nie ersetzen können. Die, die da sind, die Klasse haben wie Ebrechi Ese oder Michael Ulisse, die sind entweder zusammenverletzt oder abwechselnd. Also können kaum miteinander spielen, wenn sie drauf waren. Es gab mal eine kleine Phase Mitte Dezember. Dann sieht man sofort, okay, die sind da und die sind echt gut. Und wenn Glasner die hinbekommt, auch, dass sie gesund bleiben, dann hat er schon die Chance, dass er eben nach oben wandert. Und das ist dann auch wieder Herleitung 2.0, dass ich denke, dass Glasner sich aller Hasenhüttel in der Premier League dann beweisen will und zeigen kann, ich kann die zweimal konstant auf der 11 halten. Und jetzt kommt mal ihr, weiß ich nicht, Aston Villas oder Brightons oder wie sie alle heißen, die dann irgendwann mal sicherlich auch mal wieder einen Trainerschwund erleben werden. Aber der Kader ist gealtert wieder. Sie haben ihn stark verjüngt, als Patrick Villara gekommen ist. Sie haben sich ganz stark auf den immer selben Spielertyp gesetzt, also im Grunde Ahamada in allen Formen, auf jeder Position. Ein großgewachsen, athletisch sehr cleverer Spieler, der aber extrem viel Potenzial aufweisen muss, weil er an einzelnen Punkten noch wahnsinnig roh ist. Das haben sie dann die ganze Zeit gemacht, dass sie da jünger geworden sind, athletischer geworden sind. Im Verlaufe jetzt sind aber einige schon wieder weg davon und es sind die immer Alten da geblieben. Das heißt, das Durchschnittsalter ist durchaus wieder gestiegen. Wie immer, bei solchen Clubs geht im Sommer kleine Qualität nur, weil es immer nur 1-2 sind, aber die gehen natürlich logischerweise nicht. Ich rechne ehrlich gesagt auch mit dem eigenen Abgang im Sommer. Also Mark Gahey wird dann nicht bleiben. Hoffe ich zumindest auch für ihn, weil er muss anderswohin. Er ist echt ein guter Mann. Ich bin bei Ullise gespannt, ob sie den halten können. Der war ja schon im Sommer so gut wie bei Manchester City. Der wird sicherlich auch weitere Angebote bekommen. Esser ist einer der Dribbler der Liga. Auch da tippe ich, dass sich jemand für den interessieren wird. Tarik Mitchell auf links Verteidiger ist einer dieser Athleten, der weitergehen wird und dann gibt es noch ein paar unzufriedene Spieler auch oben drauf, die jetzt nicht das Grau d Fett machen. Aber Kader ist Platz 12 bis 14 mit Glasner. Ohne Glasner halt 15.
Dann sind wir mal gespannt, ob vielleicht Jean-Philippe Mathéter der neue Zielstürmer wird. Das mag ja Rafa auch ganz gerne.
Das ist einer der angesprochenen Unzufriedenen. Der muss sich ziemlich daneben bedommen haben im letzten halben Jahr.
Ich werde dazu nichts weiter sagen, sondern leite ganz galant in die Awards über, die wir noch besprechen wollen, in allen Ligen. Ich glaube, am längsten musste jetzt David schweigen. Deswegen darf er loslegen mit seinem MVP.
Mein MVP ist einer von zwei Spielern in der Liga, die mehr Tore als Spiele haben. Und zwar nicht, wie es gerade hieß, der gewisse Franzose. Der hat nämlich auch 21 Tore in 20 Spielen.
Das ist auch ganz stark, das bei der Besprechung der Ligue 1 zu sagen.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht über einen gewissen Franzosen, aber trotzdem wissen wir alle, wer gemeint ist. Sondern Mohamed Bamba. Der hat 5 Tore in 4 Spielen. Der spielt für Lorient, kommt aus der Elfenbeinküste, ist jetzt im Winter vom Volkswagen AC aus Österreich rüber gewechselt. Für immerhin stolze 5 Millionen. Klingt aber jetzt mit seinen aktuellen Toren durchaus wie ein Schnäppchen. Hat sich da wunderbar eingefügt. Seine 5 Tore hat er übrigens aus 2 XG erzielt. Also ich weiß, Max, du bist ja immer skeptisch, was so gewisse Statistiken angeht. Aber es zeigt zumindest, dass er seine Tore aus vergleichsweise unwahrscheinlichen Situationen auch noch reinhaut.
Also Thomas Tuchel ist Fan, das kann ich sagen.
Gleichzeitig durchaus auch noch in Zweikillinflaviert. Macht einen guten Eindruck. Und Lorient ist jetzt erstmal diese Saison nicht auf dem Abstiegsplatz.
Sehr, sehr schön. Den nehmen wir doch gerne. Marius, wen möchtest du gerne als MVP nominieren?
Ich habe da mitgebracht Lorenzo Pellegrini, den Kapitän der Roma. Der unter Mourinho, glaube ich, dass die größte Differenz zwischen dem, was er kann und zwischen dem, was er gezeigt hat, aufgewiesen hat in der gesamten Liga. Also einer der talentiertesten Mittelfeldspieler für mich der Serie A. Und einer, der auch eine tragende Rolle in das Quadra Azura spielen sollte. Aber zwischen ihm und Mourinho hat es mit dem System, das er da spielen lassen, hat irgendwie nie so richtig gepasst. Und jetzt ist ja Mourinho bekanntermaßen seit der Niederlage gegen Milan weg. Und Daniele De Rossi ist da, mit dem Pellegrini selbst noch zusammengespielt hat. Und unter dem hat er jetzt in sechs Spielen, da haben sie nur eins von verloren gegen Inter, waren auch nicht die schwersten Gegner, also tabellarisch gesehen zumindest. Immerhin auch 1-1 in Rotterdam im Europa League Playoff. Da geht es dann heute Abend ins Rückspiel. Und er hat da drei Tore, drei Vorlagen in sechs Spielen. Und zeigt endlich seit Jahren eigentlich mal wieder, war auch viel verletzt, aber zeigt endlich mal wieder das, was die Fans von einem Sohn der Stadt, also dem legitim Nachfolger von Totti und De Rossi, wenn man so will, auch wenn er nicht so das große Star ansehen hat weltweit, was sie davon immer warten. Und das finde ich sehr erwähnenswert.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen die Herzgeschichte aus der Serie A.
Genau.
Also noch mehr als der Trainer bei Napoli. Aber das ist schon irgendwie, da kommt De Rossi und auf einmal trifft Pellegrini wieder.
Und die Oma klettert halt so langsam nach oben. Jetzt sind es noch vier Punkte auf Bologna aktuell Rang 6. So sieht es aus. Nils, wen magst du uns aus La Liga präsentieren?
Ich würde mal aufgrund einer Diskussion rund um die Nationalmannschaft mal erklären, warum Toni Kroos wirklich eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielt bei Real Madrid. Jetzt nicht nur, weil er in der Liga keiner noch mehr Vorlagen hat als er. Ich glaube, wenn es darum geht zu Pässe ins letzte Drittel, da können nur Chaka und Rodri seine Zahlen matchen. Da ist er herausragend, natürlich lange Bälle, Seitenverlagerung. Das hat er immer noch drauf. Aber speziell finde ich auch spannend, dass er schon in den letzten Jahren, seit dem Casemiro-Abgang, sich auch defensiv noch mal gesteigert hat. Fast ein bisschen mit Lust und Spaß in Zweikämpfe geht. Ich habe ihn letztens bei der Pressekonferenz in Leipzig auch gefragt, woher das so kommt. Er meint einfach, dass man jetzt, wo Real Madrid öfter mit nur noch zwei zentralen Mittelfeldspielern spielt als vorher mit drei. Dass man da einfach nicht umhinkommt, öfter defensiv zu denken, auch mal in ein Kopfball-Duell zu geben. Da hat er ein bisschen gewitzelt mit mir. Offensiv ist es immer noch der genauso herausragende Kroos, wie schon die letzten Jahre, jetzt auch noch defensiv mitdenken und absolut respektiert in der Mannschaft.
Aber reicht das für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft?
Die Mentalität. Das reicht nur für Real Madrid.
Er ist auch nicht weiterentwickelt.
Also Didi Hamann hat mir gesagt.
Der Ironie-Detektor bricht hier gerade durcheinander. Ja, also nur falls noch immer noch vielleicht da draußen jemand denkt, ich glaube nicht, dass in der Rasenfunkzüberschaft jemand denkt, dass das mit dem Querpass, dass das noch irgendwie aktuell war oder jemals aktuell war. Nein, Toni Kroos wird in Spanien geliebt, auch von anderen Fanlagern, höchst genießt, höchsten Respekt. Alle beten dafür fast, dass er doch noch seinen Vertrag verlängert. Das ist ja immer noch offen und er lässt sich damit auch Zeit, auch zurecht, aber er ist mit 34 Jahren immer noch auch fit und frisch. Und wie gesagt, es macht ihm Spaß und selbst Zweikämpfe mittlerweile. Und hat er auch auf der PK gesagt von wegen, es gibt die Möglichkeit vom Nationalmannschaftstrainer und der denkt darüber nach. Also da muss man noch abwarten. Viele könnten sich vielleicht freuen, wenn er kommt. Ich glaube mir ist ein Geheimnis seiner letzten ein, zwei, drei Jahre, dass er noch mal besser ist. Und das ist eben auch, dass er diese Pausen bekommen hat. Und deswegen auch viel private Zeit hat mit seiner Familie und eben auch die Belastung besser steuern kann. Aber mal gucken, so eine Heimehm, vielleicht nimmt er die doch mit.
34 ist er kein Alter.
Also ich sag mal so.
Pepe wird jetzt bald 41, ja.
Als Nummer 4 kann man ihn doch mitnehmen. Hinter Goretzka, Kimmich, Gynurn. Warum denn nicht?
Ich dachte im Tor ein.
Vielleicht Pascal Groß, ja okay, vielleicht kämpft er mit Pascal Groß um einen zweiten Bankplatz. Aber warum denn nicht? Okay, Tronikos, sehr, sehr schöner MVP. Jetzt bin ich gerade, ja, wir müssen wieder in die Ligue 1 zurück.
Nein, England haben wir noch nicht.
England haben wir noch nicht, genau, danke, genau. Ich habe mich nämlich hier gefragt, warum ich das falsche Dokument offen habe. Danke, David, du bist der Einzige, der aufgepasst hat. Uli, wer ist dein MVP?
Wenn Nils einen nimmt, der immer hinten links schön reinfällt, um aufzubauen, nehme ich einen, der neuerlich hinten rechts reinfällt. Also, kein Poet des Weltfußballs, aber wahrscheinlich einer, der in die Nähe kommt, so Outdoor oder irgendwas. Martin Ödegård, nämlich von Arsenal, der mir gerade erstaunlich gut gefällt, der im Moment das verkörpert, was Arsenal gerade war in dem Jahr. Dann habe ich die nämlich auch schön mit untergebracht. 5 Siege in 5 Spielen erstmals in einem Kalenderjahr zum Auftakt. Der sorgt für viele, viele Bewegungen, wahnsinnig viele Rotationen, switcht noch nicht so sehr, wie ich es mir wünschen würde hier und da gegen tiefe Gegner, aber alles in einem, stellt 1 gegen 1 Situationen her, sehr, sehr passsicher, wahnsinnig einflussreich in der Offensive, gibt den schönen Fakt gegen West Ham beim 6-0. Ist er der erste Spieler in den Aufzeichnungen der Premier League gewesen, der es geschafft hat, 100 komplizierte Pässe hinzubekommen, mindestens 5 Torschossen kreiert hat und multiple Torbeteiligungen hatte und das in einem Premier League Spiel. Und das zeigt nochmal ganz gut, wie viel momentan über den läuft, auch wenn es jetzt am gestrigen Mittwochabend nicht so gut lief. Okay, das gehört dazu, glaube ich, zum Entwicklungsprozess bei Arsenal. Aber grundsätzlich ist er gerade zu einer leicht veränderten Rolle. Eben fällt jetzt etwas mehr zum Aufbau und dazu zu helfen. Und da gefällt er mir fast noch besser. Also recht viel mehr Entwicklungspotenzial kann es, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr geben bei einem einzigen Wunderkind.
Ja, genau, das ist nämlich das Ding. Da sieht man nämlich, manchmal braucht es einfach Zeit, selbst bei den hochtalentierten und hochgefeierten. Und das ist ja schön. Also ich zumindest finde das dann schön, wenn man solchen Spielern dann in der Mitte ihrer Karriere zuguckt. Und auf einmal sind die Versprechungen von früher eingetreten und dann auf einmal löst sich da was. Fast schon. Dann jetzt aber in die Liga. Ansan Hiro, David.
Mein Ansan Hiro ist Vincent Sierra. Der ist Kapitän von Toulouse, 28 Jahre alt. Und der ist unter anderem für mich der Ansan Hiro des vergangenen Spieltags, weil er Torschützer eines 30 Meter Freistoßes von Toulouse gegen Monaco war. Bei dem Monaco nur einen Mann in die Mauer gestellt hat, weil sie vermutlich davon ausgegangen sind, naja, aus der Entfernung wird er nicht aufs Tor schießen. Aber Sierra sagte anschließend, er hat gesehen, da sei Köhne aus dem Tor gegangen und da war Platz am ersten Pfosten. Und dann habe er ein bisschen geschauspielert und habe er absichtlich so getan, als hätte er sich in die andere Richtung geschaut und mit den Mitspielern kommuniziert, um da den Pass zu machen. Und dann hat er aber aufs Tor geschossen. Und damit hat Toulouse gegen Monaco gewonnen. Die Punkte können sie gut gebrauchen im Abschließkampf. Da habe ich ja gerade erwähnt, um den Relegationsplatz sehr eng zu. Die haben jetzt dreimal in Folge Ausplatz gewonnen. Monaco mit Hütte hat eine handfeste Krise am Hacken jetzt. Unter anderem dadurch, da das sieht nicht gut aus. Und Toulouse hat heute Abend ein durchaus wichtiges Europa League Spiel noch vor der Brust gegen Lissabon. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Die haben das Auswärtsspiel verloren, aber die haben ja bekanntlich in der Hinrunde auch Liverpool zu Hause geschlagen. Immerhin mit 3 zu 2 in diesem Wahnsinnsspiel. Die sind ja auch überhaupt nur in dem Europa League Pokal mit drin, weil sie Pokalsieger geworden sind in Frankreich. Also sind jetzt keine Top-Mannschaft.
Jaja, stimmt. Ach, das ist immer so schön. Ihr sagt dann immer, gegen wen die im Europa-Pokal spielen. Dann erinnere ich mich wieder. Ah ja, stimmt. Da war ja was. Hab ich ja letzte Woche gesehen. Sind einfach zu viele Partien.
Die waren in einer Gruppe mit St. Giloise. Die sind der Grund, warum St. Giloise jetzt abgestiegen ist, in die Conference League.
Genau. Ja, genau. Es kommt jetzt alles wieder. Aus dem Rückenmark nach oben. Und eben gerade dieses Liverpool-Spiel. Geile Stimmung auch. Da kann man mal gespannt drauf sein. So, Serie A. Marius, wen magst du uns noch präsentieren?
Mein Anzang-Hero ist Riccardo Orsolini vom FC Bologna. Bologna-Saison ist hier, glaube ich, auch schon das ein oder andere Mal in dieser Saison besprochen worden. Ganz begeisternd. Und Orsolini ist, glaube ich, einer, der in Italien nicht so unter dem Radar fliegt. Der ist den Leuten schon bewusst, aber international kennen ihn, glaube ich, noch nicht so viele. Und er ist einer der absolut wichtigsten Spieler im System von Thiago Motta. Also alles, was in der Offensive da so passiert, geht irgendwann auf den rechten Flügel und über ihn. Also Spielmacher-Qualitäten technisch super stark, schnell auch massiv torgefährlich. Er ist jetzt in 21 Spielen bei 9 Treffern. Er hat die kleinere Krise, die sie zu Jahresbeginn hatten. Unter anderem durch seine Tore ist die überwunden worden. Wir haben jetzt wieder vier Ligaspiel in Folge gewonnen. Und ihm fehlen jetzt nur noch zwei Treffer, um seinen eigenen persönlichen Rekord aus der Serie A zu übertreffen. Das aus der Vor-Saison 11-Tore. Und wenn er sich nicht verletzt, dann schafft er das auf jeden Fall. Und ich hoffe, dass wir ihn mit Bologna und vielleicht dann ja auch noch mit Thiago Motta nächste Saison in der Champions-Liga erleben.
Da gerät man ins Träumen. Nils, wer ist dein Ansagen-Hero?
Ich bringe einen Trainer ins Spiel, der so ein bisschen aktuell sein eigenes Monster schafft. Denn Ernesto Valverde ist ja zurück beim Athletik-Club schon zum dritten Mal Trainer. Und ja, mittlerweile ist da – Athletik steht schon immer für Druck und Pressing und Leidenschaft. Und mittlerweile sind die auch noch effizient vorne und stehen weiter sicher hinten, obwohl sie in Diego Martinez den Abwehrchef von Vasa verloren haben. Also, die spielen eine überragende Saison mittlerweile. Die Williams-Brüder wissen jetzt auch endlich, wo das Tor steht. Die haben jetzt wieder einen neuen Mittelstürmer mit Guros Seta. Da war er lange nach Arizadouris Abgang. Gab es da Probleme? Und Valverde war auch letztes Jahr schon da. War lange, okay, gute Arbeit. Aber jetzt dieses Jahr sind es mal auch zwei Punkte aktuell hinter den Champions-League-Ringen. Da könnte noch was gehen hinter Atletico. Haben auch ein gutes Polster auf Real Sociedad dahinter. 9 Punkte. Das sieht gut aus. Sie haben jetzt im Copa-Halbfinale, da sind sie im fünften Jahr in Folge dabei. Haben sie im Hinspiel bei Atletico 1-0 gewonnen mit nur 30 Prozent Ballbesitz. Aber wie gesagt, das sind keine Mannschaften, die hinten drin stehen und mauern, sondern wirklich vorne drauf gehen. Die können wirklich unangenehm sein. Kein Team presst zu hoch und kann das auch 90 Minuten durchhalten in der Liga. Also da sind sie auf Kurs von ihrem dritten Finale in diesen letzten fünf Jahren und dann auch endlich den ersten Titel. Also da ist gerade Heimspiel im Saint-Mamès absolut sehenswert bei der Zone dort. Das sind absolute Festspiele immer. Und ja, macht einfach Spaß, da eine Mannschaft zu sehen, die mit offenem Visier ins Spiel geht. Trotzdem gerne auch mal die Null hält, weil sie hinten trotzdem konzentriert sind, aber vorne mittlerweile auch effizient sind. Und da eben, wie gesagt, Ernesto Valverde liefert da sehr, sehr gute Arbeit ab.
Krass auch, wie der sich entwickelt hat. Also ich glaube, nur vor ein paar Jahren hätten wir nicht gesagt, dass das Valverde-Fußball vorne drauf und Pressing, Pressing, Pressen und so weiter. Immer natürlich schon so ein bisschen. Aber ja, verrückt.
Nicht so wie aktuell, ja.
Aber absolut. Atletik. Sehr schön und Ernesto Valverde natürlich. Uli, dein Anzang Hero.
Ich will auch die drin haben. Tabellenführer in der Premier League. Wenn man über Liverpool spricht, also keine Angst, wird nicht Jürgen Klopp, aber dann würde man vermutlich viele, viele verschiedene Namen nennen. Was weiß ich, Mohamed Salah, Davin Lunes, Diogo Giotta, der sich jetzt leider schwer verletzt hat, letztes Wochenende. Van Dijk, keine Ahnung, wer mir sonst noch einfällt, aber ich möchte mal einen hervorheben, der stellvertretend steht für etwas, das ein Top-Team braucht, und zwar HW Elliott. Er ist mit 20 Jahren jetzt schon bei seinem 100. Premier League Spiel für Liverpool angekommen. Nur mal zum Vergleich, damit man es einordnen kann, scheint Alexander-Arnold und Gerard Wan 21, als sie diesen Meilenstein erreicht haben. Und Elliott ist in der Regel kein Stammspieler, und trotzdem gehört er zum Stamm, weil er eigentlich immer eingewechselt wird. Und weil er jetzt auch in der Zeit, in der Salah bei der African Cup of Nations war, zwar nicht zahlenmäßig ersetzt hat, definitiv nicht, das war dann eher die Jogo Jota, sondern weil er einfach mit seiner Reife, hat so ein Zocker-Gen in sich, traut sich viel zu, hat immer mal so einen ganz frechen Chip mit dabei, wird aber immer besser, kriegt es hin, dass er von der Bank Energie bringt, dass er dem Spiel so etwas wie Charakter sofort verleiht. Und ich glaube, so jemanden braucht man einfach im Team, eben genau, wenn es vor allen Dingen bei Liverpool gibt, es gibt ja viele Verletzungen in der Saison, insbesondere im Mittelfeld, da ist der zu nennen. Hätte auch Endo nehmen können, der gerade als Kopfballmonster in England aufwartet. Es ist erstaunlich, wie stark der da alles rausfischt. Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, aber Harvey Elliott hat diese Award jetzt ausnahmsweise mal gegeben. Wie gesagt, stellvertretend für das, was ein Top-Team, meiner Meinung nach, braucht, so ein Supa-Sub, sagt man in England immer. Und das, glaube ich, ist er, ohne dass er jetzt die ganz großen Zahlen auflegt.
Dass der 100 Premier League Spiele für Liverpool gemacht hat, hätte ich nie im Leben gedacht. Nie im Leben. Das ist ja verrückt. Der wird ja einfach...
Er ist auch total crazy.
Seid er da, ist er einfach immer eingewechselt. Da musst du definitiv etwas haben, wenn das klappt. Sehr, sehr schöne Wahl. Dann noch die Momente der aktuellen Zeit, des Spieltags, wie auch immer euch beliebt. David, darf wieder beginnen.
Mein Moment des Spieltags ist die 88. Spielminute im Spiel Brest gegen Marseille, weil wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch mal zumindest kurz ein bisschen Brest erwähnen und loben. Da ist zu dem Zeitpunkt Brest nur noch zu Zehnt auf dem Platz, Zehn gegen Elf und Pierre-Lés Melou läuft in der gesamten Abwehr von rechts außen von Marseille vorbei und macht das Tor einfach selbst. Deswegen dann also der eingangs schon erwähnte Sieg von Brest gegen Marseille und wir haben jetzt über Marseille gesprochen, aber Brest nach wie vor auf Platz zwei. Das Fußballmärchen geht weiter. Alexi hat es auch bereits erwähnt letztes Mal, hat ja einen Schwerpunkt zu Brest. Das ist aber trotzdem schon einfach Wahnsinn. Und Lés Melou hat anschließend augenzwinkend in die Mikrofone gesagt, er hatte so eine Elfmetersituation in der ersten Hälfte und hat dann gesagt, der dann nicht gegeben wurde für Marseille und sagte dann, ja, also ich habe schon Angst gehabt, ich habe schon das Gefühl gehabt, dass das Elfmeter war, sagt wohl Gemäck, der Spieler, der gefault hat. Also holla, holla. Aber ja, sechs Punkte trennen Brest aktuell von Nicht-Europa-Plätzen.
Es geht einfach weiter. Ganz, ganz wunderbar. Marius, dein Moment des Spieltags.
Einer, der aus einer nicht so schönen Gegebenheit entstanden ist, aber das schließt sich dann irgendwie der Kreis für mich in dieser Ausgabe auch wieder einer fürs Herz ist nach dem ja doch sehr überraschenden Tod von Andy Brehme, ist das Echo, was es in Italien gegeben hat und die Ehrung seiner Person. Er hat ja für Inter gespielt zusammen mit Matthäus und Klinsmann Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er. Das finde ich unglaublich, unvergleichlich. Also wie sehr er dort Legendenstatus genießt, ich glaube, das ist in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit gar nicht so bekannt. Thomas Hörner, den ich sehr schätze, der auch Inter-Tifo ist, hat in der SZ auch darüber geschrieben, falls ich das hier mal noch durchlesen möchte, Beppe Bergum, einer der größten Intelligenten, ist am Live-Mikrofon in den Gedanken daran, an Bremen, an die gemeinsame Zeit beendet habe, auch wenn er immer wieder Mailand besucht hat und dort auch im Stadion gefeiert wurde, was die da noch zusammen im höheren Alter erlebt haben, in Tränen ausgebrochen. Also für diese traurige Nachricht, was das für eine Reaktion hervorgerufen hat, finde ich bemerkenswert und sehr, sehr erwähnenswert.
155 Spiele für Inter, über 13.000 Minuten auf dem Feld gestanden. Also absolute Inter-Legende. Sehr schön ist der falsche Begriff, aber ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, wie ich es meine. Sehr schöner Moment. Nils, es ist jetzt ein bisschen spät, danach zu kommen. Gebe ich zu, habe ich nicht darauf geachtet bei der Reihenfolge. Tut mir leid. Aber was ist dein Moment des Spieltags?
Ich dachte auch erst, nochmal den Athletik-Club zu nehmen. Da hatte Vivian im Topspiel gegen Girona das 3-3-Kurzverschluss auf der Linie abgewährt. Aber ich würde was Schönes nehmen aus der 3. Liga in Spanien. Die ist ja nicht ganz so professionell aufgestellt wie in Deutschland. Also die ist 2-klitrig mit 2 Gruppen. Und da gab es jetzt ein Spiel mit über 25.000 Zuschauern. Das war in Malaga. Den hatten wir vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt. Und da war zu Gast Recreativo. Also der Club aus Uelva. Das ist der älteste Club in Spanien, wo ich gerne mal bin. Da habe ich ein bisschen Verwandtschaft. Und das war eben für spanische Verhältnisse. Dritte Liga, über 20.000 Zuschauern. Das kommt in Malaga. Passiert schon mal auch bei Deportivo La Coruña. Aber eben dann nochmal 25.000. Das ist schon bemerkenswert, dass da eben so viel gute Stimmung war. Auch viele Auswärtsfahrer aus Uelva. Ist ja ein bisschen mal ein analogisches Derby natürlich gewesen. Das war für spanische Verhältnisse. War das sehr schöne Bilder aus dem La Rosa Leda. Und ja, kann man sich wünschen, dass solche Traditionsclubs wie Malaga Recreativo da mal wieder ein bisschen höher spielen. Zumindest mal 2. Liga, die sind aktuell 4. und 5. in dieser 2. Gruppe der 3.
Liga. 25.000, das ist schon nicht so schlecht. Habe mir gerade nachgeguckt. Drittligaschnitt in Deutschland lag letzte Saison bei 8.200. Gibt natürlich auch noch oben und noch unten.
Doch nur. Ich glaube, Spanien hat so 6.000, der Schnitt, die 3. Liga.
Da müsste ich jetzt noch mal im Detail reingucken. Man wird in diesem Jahr auf jeden Fall höher sein wegen der Absteige usw. Aber nur eben, um so grob das einzuordnen. Und dann haben wir noch einen Moment des Spieltags von Uli.
Ich nehme einen, der auch da wieder stellvertretend etwas Größeres zeigt. Eine kleine Präambel dazu. Rio Ferdinand hat vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich, in seinem TV-Interview gefragt worden, nach Weltklasse-Spielern, die es im Moment in England gibt. Und da hat er ein paar genannt, Phil Foden und so. Und dann hat irgendwann mal die Nachfrage seine Kollegin, die Monatoren gestellt, die da hieß, ja, und was ist denn mit Bukai Osaka? Und dann hat er gemeint, ne, der ist nicht Weltklasse. Und wie es dann der Zufall will, ist Rio Ferdinand gestern in der Maschine von London nach Porto, um ebenfalls wieder für die Champions League zu begleiten. Und es gibt wunderschöne Bilder von Fans, die den ganzen Linienflug über Rio Ferdinand bescheiden mit Bukai Osaka ist World Class. Und das liebe ich so an den Engländern. Das hat irgendwas Unaggressives in sich. Und trotzdem, sie können nicht aus sich raus, als ihm so zu sagen, und auch in eine schöne Art und Weise. Und das ist so der Fanatismus, den ich an den englischen Fußballfans insbesondere sehr schätze. Es ist nicht möglich, in London irgendwie durch die Straßen zu laufen. Und wenn die nur im Entferntesten mitkriegen, dass man irgendwas mit Fußball zu tun hat, dann hängen sie dir ein halbes Stunden Gespräche an und ich liebe das. Und deswegen ist das so mein Moment, der einfach nur mal ganz gut nachweist, wie es steht um Fußball in England. Ich glaube, das wird nicht so schnell aus der Kultur rausgehen.
Gott sei Dank. Wunderbar. Ein wunderbarer letzter Moment. Ihr vier. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy.
Ich habe noch Spiele to watch. Ich wollte nur noch kurz einfach sagen, wer jetzt wegen Marseille kurz reinschauen möchte. Am Sonntag, 20.45 Uhr, spielt Marseille gegen Montpellier. Und außerdem, das eigentliche Top-Spiel ist L'Anse gegen Monaco, Sonntag um 13 Uhr. Und ich hatte kurz überlegt, ob ich L'Anse als Schwerpunkt mitbringe, weil ich war ja in L'Anse beim Freiburg-Spiel. Aber, und ich weiß, Max, du bist ja auch immer jemand, der gerne Podcasts, andere Podcasts empfiehlt. Ich habe einen L'Anse-Schwerpunkt gemacht für den Podcast Freiburg vergangene Woche, 13. Februar, mit einem Titel, der dir auch sehr gefallen wird, weil der Titel heißt eine Frage der Balance. Und genau, sie spielen jetzt am Wochenende gegen Monaco. Ich hoffe, dass sie sich dann erholt haben von dem hoffentlichen Niederlage gegen Freiburg heute Abend. Hüstel, Hüstel, Hüstel. Da wird übrigens auch, auch da wird der Rückgriff, sorry, das ist gerade verlängerer, aber es ist einfach zu viele schöne Fäden, die ich hier aufgreife. Da wird der aus Beke spielen, den ich erwähnt habe Anfang der Saison mal im Spiel. Da haben wir hier in Ligatour geredet, in welchen Ligen haben schon aus Beken gespielt, unter anderem in Lens.
Wie selten in so ratlose Gesichter geguckt, wie damals, als du diese Frage gestellt hast.
Also da wird Cousinow in der Innenverleihung spielen und genau. Lens hat heute Morgen, haben die Zeitungen gesagt, also es gab doch schon mal eine Situation, wo Lens im Hinspiel gegen Deutsche nicht so gut aussah. 1999 gegen Kaiserslautern und da haben sie 4 zu 1 gegen Kaiserslautern im Rückspiel gefahren.
Du bist der Beste. Ich mache heute Abend erst in Lens. Du bist der Beste.
Okay, Gott sei Dank haben wir jetzt noch die Matches to Watch mit dabei. Hat irgendjemand sonst noch ein Match to Watch, was er loswerden will? Jetzt kann ich es ja nicht abwirken. Ja, Nils meldet sich schon.
Sergio Ramos Rückkehr ins Stadio Santiago Bernabéu nach über 3, 4 Jahren Sonntagabend. Ja, mal tritt gegen den FC Sevilla. Das könnte lustig werden.
Der will treffen. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Uli das auch macht. Nein, er bleibt ruhig.
Nö, ich habe gerade überlegt, ob wir uns nochmal treffen. Bis zum, ich glaube, 9. der 3. oder 8. der 3. ist dann das Datum für ein letztes Mal Jürgen Klopp gegen Manchester City. Das sollte man schon sehen. Das ist ja fast dann schon ein Nostalgiefaktor. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns bis dahin nochmal sehen, hören. Aber ansonsten würde ich das schon mal vorsichtshalber nahelegen.
Ja, absolut. Das nehmen wir schon mal auf die Liste. Und Marius, gibt es in der Serie A noch was, auf das wir blicken sollten?
Nicht ganz so groß wie die Rückkehr von Sergio Ramos zur Real. Aber Charles de Quetellare spielt mit Atalanta am Sonntagabend und 20.45 Uhr bei Milan. Da lief es ja für ihn gar nicht gut. Jetzt bei Atalanta ist er richtig gut. Und ich glaube, das könnte ein ganz ansehnliches Fußballspiel werden.
Sehr gut. Ich dachte, du kommst mit Juve gegen Frau Sinone. Aber auch das…
Ja, also warum nicht?
Bist du auch einer Ligre Versteher, wie ich das dann erinnere?
Das führen wir demnächst mal aus. Vielleicht machen wir mal so eine Gruppentherapie-Sitzung. Dann könnt ihr das einfach mal ausdiskutieren. Ihr sehr, ihr A-Experten. Ihr vier, es war wie immer ganz, ganz fantastisch von euch. Ich werde mit euch, ich werde alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann und so weiter. Ich habe mir hier mal eifrig notiert, wenn wir irgendwas angesprochen haben. Das heißt, es wird auch Links geben, die wir hier erwähnt haben. In den Show Notes, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke an Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy, Marius Soyke und Uli Hebel. Danke euch vier. Das ist wie, wenn der Lehrer guten Morgen sagt. Und ich danke auch allen Hörerinnen und Hörern und allen Supporterinnen und Supportern. Der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. Keine Investoren hier, außer euch. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich danken Henry, Daniel, Boivot, Patrick E. Chancentot, Mattes und Paladinus. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sich auch als Supporterinnen registriert, damit ich sie hier nennen kann. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr noch ganz, ganz viele andere Folgen. Hört unbedingt rein. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.